Hallo, moin Leute, ich bin noch ein bisschen früher da, ich konnte heute nicht rennen, weil alles immer noch zugefroren ist, sagen wir mal eine Mischung aus zugeschneit und zugefroren ist, da falle ich aufs Maul, wenn das kein gescheiter deutscher Satz war, aber ihr wisst was ich meine, ich muss ja rausgucken, ist alles immer noch weiß und zugeschneit und zugefroren, konnte ich nicht mal eine Runde rennen heute, ich werde es überleben.
Letzte zwei Wochen war insgesamt eh ein bisschen wenig, ich glaube ich war die letzten zwei Wochen bloß zweimal in der Woche oder so, was mit dem Wetter zusammenhängt, weil bei Glatteis hast du keinen Bock, und bei komplett zu kannst du auch schlecht, also ich könnte ein bisschen mehr Fahrrad fahren dafür, also hier auf meinem Smart Trainer aber.
So spannend ist es auch nicht, das mache ich nur ab und zu mal, so eine Stunde, also spannend ist es echt.
Und das schon mit App, ja, und Chat, was ging so diese Woche, naja sehr interessant, was ich gelesen habe bei Heise, können wir uns mal gerade zusammen angucken, eigentlich das und das auch nicht und das auch nicht und das auch nicht, was ich mir mit euch angucken wollte ist folgendes, also ist mir gerade eingefallen, aber was wir machen können ist folgendes, und zwar,
das hat mich mal wieder sehr, das ist so typisch Deutschland Geschichte hier wieder gewesen, die ich gesehen habe per, bei Heise in den News, und zwar gab es da einen Artikel über, hier,
Gericht sieht Nutzung von Klartextpasswörtern als Hack an.
Weiß nicht, hat das jemand von euch gelesen?
Es ist total, also, kurze Zusammenfassung, wobei hier steht es eigentlich, ja nicht wirklich, also,
kurze, kurze Zusammenfassung, für alle, die es nicht gelesen haben, wo man wieder sieht, dass es in Deutschland echt voll für den Arsch geregelt ist.
Ein Hacker-Man, oder ein Software-Analyse-Typ, wurde beauftragt, von einem Unternehmen zu gucken, was er denn so in der bei ihnen eingesetzten Software für Sicherheitsprobleme finden kann.
Kommt ja öfters mal vor.
Gerade, gerade im Bankenumfeld und im Versicherungsumfeld.
Kann ich euch ja aus eigener Erfahrung berichten, habe ich jetzt ja beides durch.
Ist dann öfters der Fall, dass da irgendwelche Leute Zeug analysieren, zumindest.
Unternehmer hat einen beauftragt, und der hat in einem, in einem, in einem Software-Paket, von einem Drittanbieter, quasi, was sie sich gekauft haben,
hat er festgestellt, dass ein Passwort dort im Klartext drinne steht.
So.
Was hat er jetzt gemacht?
Er hat das Plaintext-Passwort genommen und eine Connection damit aufgebaut, dorthin, wo sich die Software auch verbindet.
Und er ist dann bei irgendeiner Datenbank rausgekommen, vom Hersteller, die anscheinend so public verfügbar war, mit einem Plaintext-Passwort in der Software, also Software, an die auch jeder drankommt.
Ja.
Und.
Dann hat er sich gedacht, okay, das ist vielleicht nicht so geil, dass man so easy da drankommt, aber.
Werden ja nur die Daten von meinem Kunde drin gespeichert sein.
Waren aber nicht.
Waren die Daten von allen Kunden dieses Drittanbieters drin gespeichert.
Und als er das gemerkt hat, hat er sich disconnected, weil ist ja verboten.
Hat den Anbieter, also hat, glaube ich, den, seinen Auftraggeber informiert, hat den Anbieter der Drittanbieter-Software informiert und hat sich, damit der Drittanbieter sich auch drum kümmert, glaube ich, auch noch an irgendeine Presse,
an irgendeine Zeitung oder so gewandt, nicht ganz sicher, wie das genau gewesen ist, können wir gleich reingucken.
Und was ist daraufhin passiert?
Der Anbieter der Software hat die Sicherheitslücke gepatcht, okay, ist ja schon mal gut, könnte man sagen, und hat den Programmierer angezeigt, wegen Hacker-Man-Shit, nachdem er in Deutschland, fragt mich nicht, welcher Paragraph das ist, das war so allgemein unter Hacker-Paragraph-Löchern.
Das war so allgemein unter Hacker-Paragraph-Löchern.
Und die Begründung ist, soweit ich das hier gesehen habe, dass er ja das Passwort nicht einfach Plaintext in der Anwendung direkt stehen hatte, so wie man normalerweise darauf zugreifen kann, sondern er hat die Anwendung zur Analyse in einem Hex-Editor geöffnet und dort das Plaintext-Passwort gefunden.
Also wenn Dateien in einem Hex-Editor öffnen, oder ich glaube, er sagt sogar, er hat das nur in der Anwendung.
Also wenn Dateien in einem Hex-Editor öffnen, oder ich glaube, er hat das nur in der Anwendung.
auch als er das festgestellt hat sich direkt ist connected und dann den bescheid gesagt aber
trotzdem wurde verurteilt also das ist absolut bescheuert massive pp er hätte theoretisch nach
finden des passports also wir lassen wir überlegen wie hat er sich korrekt verhalten sollen tja es
ist enorm schwierig korrekt also korrektes verhalten in der richtung wäre gewesen die
software in einem hex editor aufzumachen zu sehen da ist ein plaintext passwort drin und
dann zu sagen ich kann an der stelle nicht weitermachen weil ich mich zu einer datenbank
konnte aber das hätte er an der stelle gar nicht wissen können ja dass das irgendwie also es ist
es ist super weird das macht aus meiner sicht keinen sinn und so das übrigens auch ein problem
so bleiben sicherheitslücken bestehen ja das meinte wie viele leute das jetzt abschreckt
was ähnliches zu machen da kommt der nächste typ her das feststellt und nicht so nett ist und das
an den herstellern
meldet und damit irgendwas anstellt durch genau so was vom daten leaks unter anderem ich hoffe
dass sie noch richtig große probleme bekommen die modern solutions leute durch diesen ganzen
fall vor allem auch durch die mediale aufmerksamkeit die das so auf sich zieht
deswegen kann ich nicht oft genug betonen dass die firma modern solutions heißt und
vielleicht fällt ihnen dann mal was besseres ein in zukunft als leute die sie auf sicherheitslücken
hinweisen zu verklagen dass das weiß ich nicht keine ahnung ich weiß nicht wie das abgelaufen
ist also für mich ließ sich das so als hat er sich an die firma gemeldet als hatte sie an die
firma gemeldet hat aber gleichermaßen sich das ist aber glaube ich auch nicht unüblich dass man sagt
hey, wir halten das bis zum so und sovielten zurück und dann übergeben wir das der Presse und so was.
So ein bisschen, dass man ein bisschen Druck dahinter hat, dass sie sich auch drum kümmern.
Ja, offensichtlich kann man das.
Und das war auch erfolgreich an der Stelle, weil der hat verloren und ist jetzt wahrscheinlich vorbeschraft wegen Computerkriminalität,
auch wie immer man das nennt, und findet wahrscheinlich keinen Job mehr.
Also, ziemlich für den Arsch für ihn, ne?
Weil das jetzt meine Interpretation der Sache ist, keine Ahnung, ob das stimmt.
So, jetzt haben wir alles geupdatet.
Ich muss gerade mal eine Runde Package-Updates machen, das schadet nichts.
Wenn wir schon gerade dabei sind, gibt es hier irgendwas Neues?
Obdates?
Nein, Obdates.
Reboot.
Ne, das Öffnen in dem Hex-Editor, das habe ich vielleicht auch nicht ganz korrekt gesagt vorhin.
Das Öffnen im Hex-Editor.
Das Öffnen im Hex-Editor ist tatsächlich gar nicht der Punkt gewesen, was ihm zum Verhängnis wurde,
sondern das Benutzen des Passwortes, um danach...
Also, er hat ja das Programm in einem Text-Editor, in einem Hex-Editor,
ich vermute, in einem heißartiglichen Text-Editor, aber ich vermute, dass sie Hex-Editor meinen,
geöffnet hat, das Passwort rausbekommen, und das, worauf man sich dann quasi...
Das Problem war, dass er das Passwort benutzt.
hat, um damit sich dann zu einer Datenbank zu connecten.
Also, das Connecten auf die Datenbank mit diesem Passwort war das Problem.
Und das wurde so gesehen, dass quasi er durch Reverse-Engineering der Software quasi Zugangsdaten gefunden hat,
um sich dann unerlaubterweise Zugang zu einer geschützten Datenbank zu verschaffen.
Das ist das eigentliche Problem gewesen.
Und...
Inwieweit das Öffnen eines Binarys in einem Hex-Editor Reverse-Engineering ist,
und, ja, das Ausführen von MySQL minus C minus P minus was auch immer,
ich weiß nicht, wie man den MySQL-Command-Line-Client bedient,
Hacking ist, kann man sich drüber streiten, das Gericht sah das so als gegeben an.
Man speichert Passwörter im Plaintext normalerweise gar nicht,
Hardcoded im System.
Es wäre sinnig gewesen, also, das, okay, reden wir mal kurz drüber, wie man das richtig macht,
wie das der Hersteller richtig gemacht hätte.
Da gibt es zwei Sachen, also jetzt nach dem, was man aus dem Artikel rauslesen kann.
Also, das erste ist, Passwörter speichert man nicht im Source-Code Hardcoded.
Das zweite ist, also, das ist der erste Punkt, so was macht man überall.
Über eine Config-Datei, ob die jetzt gesortet sind oder nicht, erst mal, äh, wurscht.
Wichtig ist, dass die nicht irgendwie im Source-Code gespeichert werden,
dass das jeder, der Zugriff auf das Binary hat, auslesen kann.
Das nächste ist, warum ist das ein Hardcoded-Passwort,
das man ja anscheinend auch nicht ändern kann,
und warum ist der, das ist das eigentliche Problem,
warum verbindet er sich direkt auf eine Datenbank, die dann auch für alle Kunden ist.
Also, das ist das, das ist der eigentliche Knackpunkt.
Wenn es jetzt eine eigene Datenbank gewesen wäre, für diesen speziellen Kunden, dann ist es immer noch bescheuert,
aber es wäre, hätte es sich in Grenzen gehalten.
Normalerweise, korrekterweise würde man es so machen, aus meiner Sicht, ja,
korrekterweise würde man es so machen, in der Software wird kein Passwort gespeichert,
und man stellt keine direkte Datenbankverbindung her zum, zur Backend-Datenbank, sondern,
auf Hersteller-Seite läuft irgendwo eine Datenbank-Cluster,
der kann meinetwegen auch alle Daten aller Kunden enthalten, wenn es sein muss, ja, spricht ja nichts dagegen.
Auf Backend-Seite davor ist eine Backend-Anwendung, ja,
wurscht, ob das C-Sharp, Java, Python, was auch immer ist, eine Backend-API,
die eine Backend-Anwendung, die ein Public-Endpunkt bereitstellt, also irgendeine API oder irgendein Graph-SQL-Endpunkt,
oder, äh, GraphQL-Endpunkt, oder was auch immer, irgendeinen API-Endpunkt bereitstellt,
auf den sich die Software dann connectet, und die auch ordentliche Authentifizierung macht,
und nicht irgendwie Datenbank, MySQL-Passwörter, sondern wo es halt dann ein User-Management drinne gibt,
wo du dann beispielsweise auch Kunden anlegen kannst, jeder Kunde, kriegt ein eigenes Login,
und die verbinden sich dann an den Web-Endpunkt, die Software verwendet sich, verwendet sich,
verbindet sich mit seinen Authentifizierungen,
die dort lokal in der Config-Datei gespeichert werden, zu deinem Backend,
und das Backend, das hat Zugriff auf die Datenbank.
Die Datenbank Public im Internet ist eh schon mal eine doofe Idee.
Genau.
Das ist doch, das ist auch das, was ich gesagt hab.
So, so würde man es normalerweise machen.
Also die Datenbank Public im Internet haben ist doof.
Und dann Public im Internet haben mit einem hardcoded Passwort im Source-Code,
und dann alle Kundendaten drin.
Das ist, das ist nicht, da reicht doppel-doof schon nicht.
Das ist, wie war das bei 1984?
Doppel-plus-doof.
Also, so würde man es eigentlich richtig machen.
Das ist, das ist, ja.
Das ist schon fast C++-doof, ja.
Naja, in dem Fall ja schon.
Du hast ja auf der ganzen Welt deine, deine Datenbanken verteilt,
und willst du über das Internet darauf zugreifen, was willst du machen?
Ich meine, du könntest auch, du könntest auch sagen, hey, alle bekommen irgendwelchen,
VPN-Zugang oder so, aber das macht's für mich einfach nur komplizierter.
Von der Architektur ist das am sinnigsten.
Du hast irgendeinen, irgendeinen API-Endpunkt.
Also, brauchst du nicht, aber in dem Fall ist eigentlich das, das Sinnigste, was man machen kann.
Ja, ernsthaft?
Nur noch Shit.
Hab ich noch nie geguckt.
Ich hab noch nie in meinem Leben Dschungelcamp geguckt, Leute.
Ich hab auch noch nie in meinem Leben Big Brother geguckt.
Ich hab auch noch nie in meinem Leben...
Deutschland sucht...
Ne, wie heißt das?
Germany's Next Topmodel geguckt?
Das einzige, was ich mal angucken musste, und das ist ultra dumm, ist die Shopping Queen.
Das hätt ich auch nicht wirklich sehen müssen.
Naja.
So, so viel, so viel dazu.
Also, man sieht mal wieder, in Deutschland ist das alles möglich.
Wir sind halt noch in der Fax-Ära unterwegs.
Dann gucken wir uns doch mal an, was dieses...
Was dieses...
Was diese Woche auf Shit-Hub getrendet ist.
Wie immer, wir überspringen alle AI- und Machine-Learning-Sachen.
Personal Finance and Wealth Management App.
Okay, Leute.
Da könnt ihr eure Millionen managen mit.
Oh, die sieht schon mal fancy aus.
Das muss man ihnen lassen.
Es sieht, wisst ihr was, es sieht eins zu eins aus wie Scalable.
Das ist ohne Scheiß, das ist das Farbschema, die Graphen, das ist eins zu eins die Scalable-App.
Also, entweder sind die super krass inspiriert.
Das muss ich mal kurz aufmachen.
Ich muss das grad mal vergleichen bei mir auf dem...
Ohne Scheiß, das ist exakt die Schriftart, die Farben, die Graphen, die Prozentanzeige.
Das ist original, die Scalable-App, Mann.
Also, entweder sind die ganz hart inspiriert davon in einer von beiden Richtungen.
Man weiß ja nie, wer da zuerst gewesen ist.
Ist Scalable auch Homesource?
Nee.
Ich muss mal gucken, ob irgendjemand schon aufgefallen ist hier, dass es aussieht wie Scalable.
Nee, noch keine müssen jetzt anscheinend.
Okay.
China, Chinesen, Englisch.
How to?
Weeps in?
AI?
ATMX?
Facebook-Stelz?
AI?
Angular?
Keck, wait.
Okay, nicht so viel Spannendes die Woche dabei.
Sind wir schnell durch.
Gibt's das eigentlich auf YouTube?
Alter, was ist mit den Shorts wieder los, Mann?
Hört euch diese Gender-Scheiße an.
Geht ja schon gut los.
Was ist mit den YouTube-Shorts wieder, Alter?
Was haben wir da als nächstes?
Arbeit abzunehmen.
How to get promoted in your job.
Ah, er wieder am Start.
Der Uhren-Liebhaber.
Alter, was ist mit den...
Was...
Was geht mit den Shorts wieder?
Okay, Chatge, wir hören uns jetzt an, wie man eine Promotion bekommt, okay?
Wenn es darum geht.
Also, Promotion.
Promotion.
Wie werden wir befördert?
Auf geht's.
Ähm...
Da kommt wahrscheinlich...
Ich muss sagen, ich habe außer zwei, drei Shorts von ihm noch nichts gesehen.
Das hatte leichte Comedy-Gruppe-Vibes.
Ich bin mir da aber nicht sicher.
Also, ich hoffe, es kommt jetzt nicht.
Du brauchst das Hardcore-Crimeset-Mindset, weil dann...
Wie macht man Shorts eigentlich lauter, Leute?
Ich glaube, man kann das Video nehmen.
Und dann kann man sagen...
Watch und macht das hinten dran.
Dann geht das, glaube ich.
Wenn es darum geht, man möchte eine Beförderung...
Okay, man möchte eine Beförderung.
Auf geht's.
... oder so.
Oder wie erreicht man das am besten?
Schaut mal.
Wenn ihr...
Also, es gibt...
Okay.
Ich sage nichts.
Wir gucken uns das mal an.
... sagt, ich komme mit meinem Job nicht weiter.
Ja?
Und der...
Ich sage, Job auch kacke.
... Chef möchte mir die Beförderung nicht geben.
Oder ich sitze da fest und so weiter.
Vielleicht sagt man auch einfach.
Die beste Taktik, um mit dem Job nach vorne zu kommen.
Ganz, ganz kurz und ganz, ganz einfach.
Guckt derjenige, der ein bis zwei Etagen über euch ist.
Guckt, was der macht.
Und versucht ihm ganz gezielt Arbeit abzunehmen.
Egal, ob du gefragt wirst oder nicht gefragt wirst.
Guckt, was er macht.
Nimmt ihm Arbeit ab.
Nimmt das auf deine Schultern.
Kümmere dich darum.
Und dann wirst du sehen.
Du wirst weiterkommen.
Und nicht so.
Ja, also, ich arbeite jetzt ja schon zwei Jahre hier.
Und ich möchte jetzt eine Gehaltserhöhung, weil ich schon zwei Jahre arbeite.
Kannst du machen.
Alles gut.
Mach das Ganze.
Ich sage nur, wenn du es anders tust, wird das Ganze deutlich leichter.
Und du wirst auch dich weiterentwickeln von deinen Skills.
Weil, was die Arbeitnehmer nicht verstehen, ist, ihr macht das nicht für den Arbeitgeber.
Ihr eignet euch selber Eigenschaften an, die ihr dann eventuell...
Naja, ich glaube, die meisten Leute machen das, weil sie keinen Bock haben, unter der
Brücke zu schlafen.
... auch weiter benutzen können und diese Arbeitsstelle als Sprungbrett zu nehmen.
Ist jetzt schon was Wahres dran.
Aber, also, ich sehe es ein bisschen anders.
Das ist jetzt sehr allgemein.
Okay, glücklicherweise war das kein 0815, komm in die Gruppe, Grindset Mindset.
Also, ich finde...
Das ist etwas zu BWL-lastig gedacht alles.
Ich glaube, er denkt bei Beförderung nur so an Management-Kram.
So nach dem Motto, den einzigen Weg von Beförderung oder von Gehaltserhöhung ist mehr Management-Kram
machen.
Das finde ich ja an sich schon nicht den richtigen Ansatz.
Ich denke, gerade in etwas größeren Unternehmen ist es wichtig, dass man den Leuten mehrere
Möglichkeiten gibt.
Wie sie sich entspannen.
Ja.
Also, dass sie sich entspannen halten können.
Unter anderem nicht nur Personalverantwortung, Management, Projekte und sonst was, sondern
auch fachliche Themen.
Und was man auch nicht vergessen darf, also, ich glaube, er denkt bei Beförderung hauptsächlich
an irgendwie Management-Kram und nachdem wir aber alle nicht unbedingt hier im BWL-Umfeld
aktiv sind, ist das für uns, glaube ich, nicht so ganz anwendbar und ich glaube, die
Leute ticken da auch ein bisschen anders.
Also, ich denke, wichtig ist, dass es mehrere Möglichkeiten gibt.
Und einer der Aufgaben deines Chefes ist es ja unter anderem auch, die Leute dahingehend
zu fördern, wenn sie Bock haben.
Ja.
Zum Beispiel, wenn irgendjemand Ambitionen hat, mal Software-Architekt zu werden, dass
man ihm das auch ermöglicht.
Natürlich muss der Typ am Ende das auch können, die Motivation mitbringen, sich da reinzuhängen
und auch gewisse Skills haben, die eben für die Position notwendig sind.
Und man darf auch nicht vergessen.
Ja.
Man darf auch nicht vergessen, dass das in unserem Umfeld gar nicht wirklich gut funktioniert.
Weil, überlegt mal, ihr würdet jetzt gucken, ja, was macht denn mein Abteilungsleiter?
Wie kann ich dem Arbeit abnehmen?
Das ist ein komplett anderes Tätigkeitsfeld, das hat mit deinen Aufgaben nichts zu tun,
das hat mit deinen Stärken oftmals nichts zu tun in der Technik, das hat oftmals auch
mit dem, was man persönlich machen möchte, gar nichts zu tun.
Also, ich glaube, das war echt so eine Sache.
Also, ich glaube, das war eine Sache, die sich rein an BWL-Kreisel, Business-Kreisel-Crime
richtet.
Und da ist ja schon, ist ja schon sicherlich was logisch, was, wie soll man sagen, was
war es dran?
Ich glaube, eine Sache, die ich ja auch schon öfters gesagt habe, wichtig ist, dass man
über das spricht, was man macht, dass die Leute das mitbekommen.
Weil es ist einfach so, wenn ihr die Auswahl habt zwischen eine geile Sache machen, also
sagen wir, ihr habt 100 Prozent der Zeit, ja.
Und ihr verwendet 100 Prozent der Zeit, äh, ihr verwendet 50 Prozent der Zeit dazu, eine
geile Sache zu machen und 50 Prozent der anderen Zeit darüber zu reden, was ihr für eine
geile Sache gemacht habt, ist das besser, als 100 Prozent der Zeit geile Sachen machen.
Das unterm Strich kommt das für euch was Besseres raus, so auch in der IT, auch in
der Technik.
So blöd das klingt.
Wenn ihr was Cooles auf die Reihe gekriegt habt, dann verwendet die nächste Zeit hauptsächlich
darauf, drüber zu reden, was ihr für tolle Sachen auf die Reihe gekriegt habt.
Weil es bringt euch nichts.
Es bringt nichts, nur tolle Sachen zu machen, es müssen die Leute, die da drüber entscheiden,
dass man auch was bekommt für die tollen Sachen, die man gemacht hat, das ja auch irgendwie
mitbekommen.
Und die einfachste Variante ist, wenn ihr einen gescheiten Chef habt, der sich auch
für euch einsetzt, wenn der das schon mal mitbekommt.
Es ist sicherlich nicht verkehrt, wenn es auch direkt der da oben drüber mitbekommt,
aber zumindest euer Chef sollte es mitbekommen haben, wenn es was Cooles Neues gibt, ja.
Das heißt, man sollte nicht davor zurückschrecken, etwas...
Selbstbeweihräucherung in Maßen zu betreiben.
Das ist nicht verkehrt, auch wenn es einem doof vorkommt, ja.
Auch wenn es einem blöd vorkommt.
Wir hatten mal jemanden, ich weiß, das bringe ich als Beispiel öfters, wir hatten mal jemanden
auf der alten Arbeit, wo ich war, ein, äh, aus Russland kam der, wir hatten mal total
viele Russen und der war super ruhig, ja, der hat nie was gesagt und hat aber den ganzen
Tag...
Das ist übrigens der Gleiche, der auch nicht gesagt hat, Max, was tippst du da für einen
Mist, sondern der immer gesagt hat, ähm, der immer von der Seite dich angeguckt hat und
du musstest dann merken, dass er dich anguckt, dann hast du ihn gefragt, na, was gibt's denn,
dann hat er gesagt, ja, also, es gibt auch Möglichkeiten, das anders zu machen.
Und wenn der gesagt hat, es gibt auch Möglichkeiten, das anders zu machen, hieß das übersetzt,
ich guck dir schon seit 20 Minuten zu und wundere mich, was du für einen Kack machst,
so.
Also, der war so super, wie nennt man das, so super polite, ich bin zu dämlich mit deutschen
Wörtern, so, super, äh, nett, ja, der war viel, der war super nett und der hat den
ganzen Tag super high IQ Sachen gemacht, aber es hat keiner mitgekriegt und am Ende hab
ich tatsächlich auf höherer Management-Ebene gehört, dass die sich gefragt haben, was
macht der eigentlich den ganzen Tag, die wussten das nicht.
Das ist aber zwei Fails, erster Fail, dass er's nicht richtig verkauft hat, was er tolle
Sachen macht.
Zweiter Fail, sein direkter Chef, der hätte es mitkriegen müssen.
Da sind immer, sind immer zwei Sachen dabei, also man muss tatsächlich über das reden,
was man macht.
Ja, und dann noch was allgemeines, anstatt dem Chef immer an den Lippen zu hängen und
sich einzuschleimen, zumindest hat sich das für mich ein bisschen in dem Video so angehört,
es gibt noch, gerade in der Technik, eine andere Möglichkeit, befördert zu werden,
beziehungsweise, letztendlich ist die Beförderung ja wurscht, mehr Geld zu bekommen, das ist
was, was BWL-Leute.
Ja.
Man kann mir doch sagen, ich bin doch schon mal der Chef der Technik.
Ja, ich glaube, der Chef der Technik, der hat quasi, ich weiß nicht, wie es der erste
Mal, das eine Training mit der Technik, dass man sich da ein bisschen, in der Technik
gemacht hat.
Ja.
Oder was die Anleitung, und ich denke, meine lattische Beförderung ist, dass man sich
auch manchmal, was man auch nicht leicht sucht, zu was man gewünscht haben kann.
Ja.
Also, ich glaube, dass man sich das, was man gerne hören oder oft nicht klar ist oder
können was man verlangt weil man eben was kann nichtsdestotrotz ist schon was wahres dran man
muss es gut verkaufen was man macht das steht außer frage das muss das musste ich auch lernen
dass das was das denn der peinliche absturz von nfc ist jetzt kein nerv drauf guck mal
fireship hat neues video was du kannst du dir die psik anschauen das ist ein china chat ki
ich habe es geschafft dass vermutlich meine nachbar war was meine nachricht von einer
person durch was ist das eine per diep sie generierte chat nachricht raus weil es ergibt
genauso wenig sinn wie eigene geräte nachrichten teilweise das ist das ist wahr ja das ist richtig
auch so ein ding wenn man der technik ist man spricht gerne den managern leuten die fähigkeit
ab weil dass man dazu auch was braucht aber ich glaube das liegt daran dass es enorm viele
unterschiedliche nachrichten gibt und das ist ein bisschen schwierig das ist ein bisschen
schwierig wenn man sich nicht auch aus dem mund auf das system konzentriert weil manですね
auch das ist ne wichtige aufgabe ist und sagen wir gesagt ein gewisses talent benötigt das geschalt zu
machen aber es gibt halt auch enorm viele leute ist nicht gescheit können ihr gibt sie den it
übrigens auch etwas wie bei allem also 90 der leute können halt das eigentlich gar nicht richtig aber
und das muss man sagen das ist mein persönlicher eindruck wir könnten ja mal sagen ob ihr das oder
auch du vielleicht aus manager wenn sich auch wieder dass ähnlich sie hat mein persönlich
eindruck ist es ist deutlich angare das ist deutlich angare bei den man след ein anderes
einfacher, eine Stelle
aktuell
als Techniker zu finden, wenn man
Ahnung hat, als als BWLer
zu finden, wenn man Ahnung hat.
Also im Management-Umfeld was zu finden,
selbst wenn man weiß, was man macht,
ist deutlich schwieriger, als in der Technik
eine Stelle zu finden, wenn man weiß, was man macht.
In der IT hast du
das Ding, wenn du was kannst, was begehrt
ist, dann
musst du eigentlich noch nicht mal aktiv selbst was machen,
sondern es reicht, wenn du das auf irgendein Profil
schreibst und wartest, dass sich die Leute
bei dir bewerben, was ich nicht unbedingt
so sinnvoll finde,
weil du kannst es vergessen,
was auf LinkedIn und so reinkommt.
Aber ich habe den Eindruck, dass es in der
Technik deutlich einfacher ist, Jobs
zu finden, wenn man ein bisschen Plan hat, als
wenn man BWLer ist, der ein bisschen Plan hat, zur Zeit
zumindest. Und wahrscheinlich auch
in
näherer und mittlerer Zukunft.
Ja gut, ab einer gewissen
Ebene verstehe ich das.
Da gehst du mit den
Leuten Tennis oder Golf spielen, dann weißt du Bescheid.
Das ist ja auch Klischee,
da gehen auch nicht alle Golf oder Tennis
spielen. Ja, das ist
China-Chinesen-AI, das wundert mich nicht.
In meiner Linux-VM
brauchen plötzlich alle Anwendungen mehrere Sekunden
zu arbeiten. Hast du eine Idee? Ja.
Installier dir. Achso, hast
du Arch-Linux?
Wenn nicht, ist das dein Problem?
Dass du keine Arch-Linux hast?
Weil
wenn du Arch-Linux hast, dann
würde ich sagen, installier dir mal den LTS-Körnel.
Und boote mit dem LTS-Körnel.
Das mache ich auch öfters, wenn es irgendwelche Probleme
gibt. Ich hatte ja auch mal das Problem, dass es
richtig geleckt hat. Das sah dann ungefähr so aus.
Guck, ich habe O gedrückt
und dann hat es hier geleckt und dann hat es erst
weitergeschrieben und so. Ah, du hast den
LTS-Körnel hier, dann weiß ich auch nicht, was
ist. Hast du deine
VM aus Versehen auf eine andere Platte geschoben
oder so? Ne, keine Ahnung.
Ah, doch!
Ich habe eine Idee. Falls du
VMware-Sachen abgegradet hast,
sowas in letzter Zeit. Es gab mal ein Problem,
mit VMware, dass die
standardmäßig sich
wenn du eine 13.900k
hast zum Beispiel,
dass die sich standardmäßig an die
wie heißen die Dinger?
Efficiency-Cores und Performance-Cores,
gell? Bei den
neueren Intel-CPUs. Dass sich die
VMs standardmäßig nur an die Efficiency-Cores
attached haben. Warum? Auch immer.
Und du immer auf den langsamen
CPU-Cores gelaufen bist.
Aber das dürfte eigentlich alles mittlerweile
gefixt sein. Keine Ahnung, weil ich habe auch noch
die letzte oder vorletzte
VMware-Version. Das ist kein Problem.
Echt.
LinkedIn vs. Xing in Deutschland. LinkedIn.
Xing ist tatsächlich so ein deutsches Ding.
Verstehe ich nicht. Aber insgesamt
verbreitungsmäßig eindeutig LinkedIn.
Ich muss aber sagen, ich spreche
nicht aus persönlicher Erfahrung, weil ich habe
kein LinkedIn-Profil. Ich habe kein Xing-Profil
und ich habe nur ein Fake-LinkedIn-Profil.
Ja. Kommt keiner drauf,
dass nicht ich das bin.
Gemeinsame Kontakte ansehen.
Natürlich, natürlich. Peter Aguilé hat nur
weibliche Follower. Logisch.
Obviously.
Kann das sein, dass meine Leute den...
Warum haben Leute mein...
mein Profil kopiert?
Ach, guck mal.
Der hat zufälligerweise die gleichen
gemeinsamen Kontakte.
Warum haben Leute...
Hey, sein Coach bei Google. Ja, ist klar.
Ist klar.
Ja, die vermehren sich.
Wie vermehren die sich? Durch Zellteilung.
Oder so.
Was bedeutet Kreiselgrind?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Wie die Definition von
Kreiselgrind. Also.
Das ist
eigentlich so ein Wort, was der
Friseur und ich
kreiert haben zu Zeiten, wo wir noch
viel MMOs gespielt haben.
Grind ist ja allgemein
bekannt, denke ich. Grind ist im Gaming-Kontext
quasi wiederholtes
Abarbeiten der gleichen Aufgaben.
So.
Quests mehrfach machen.
Die gleichen Mob-Cams.
Irgendwie 5 Stunden am Stück
killen und sowas.
Und Kreiselgrind ist
im Prinzip die...
Der Akt des Grindens.
Also wenn ich
für 5 Stunden am Stück
irgendwelche Monster
kille in MMOs für einen Drop,
dann ist das Kreiselgrind. Weil ich mache
im Kreis immer den gleichen Grind.
Okay?
Wir haben das immer
Kreiselgrind genannt.
Ich glaube, das Wort verwendet sonst niemand
außer wir. Ich lasse mal gucken, wenn ich
nach Kreiselgrind suche, was da rauskommt.
Okay, ich bin der Einzige, der ernsthaft
das Wort
Kreiselgrind verwendet.
Ich würde mir einfach wünschen,
wenn sie den Kreiselgrind mit
etwas Schmackhaften garnieren.
Das ist doch irgendein
AI-generierter Sinnlos-Content, oder?
Was ist das?
Ja.
Der Rest, das bin einfach nur ich.
Ich bin der Einzige, der... Oh nein, Postleitzahl liegt.
Das sind die
Einzigen, ich bin der Einzige, der
Kreiselgrind verwendet anscheinend. Aber jetzt weißt du auch,
was Kreiselgrind ist.
Microsoft Copilot gekündigt.
Ja, good luck, have fun.
Ich habe es erst gar nicht abgeschlossen.
Ich hatte mal, ich hatte mal
Copilot, aber
ich bin nie so hundertprozentig auf den Geschmack
gekommen von Copilot.
Also ich muss sagen, die...
die Shorts werden echt immer schlimmer.
Es gibt auch irgendein Browser-Plugin,
habe ich letztens gesehen.
Ah, meine eigene.
Meine neue.
Ich muss View-Time generieren.
Sekunde.
Also...
Ja.
Jetzt habe ich vergessen, was ich sagen wollte.
Lol.
Ich darf nicht immer auf den zweiten Bildschirm gucken.
Das lenkt mich ab.
Ach so, ja.
Es ist selten was dabei,
dass ich so feiere bei Shorts.
Ich glaube, ich muss mal irgendein Plugin benutzen,
um Shorts auszublenden.
Smarte neue Fenstergriffe.
Ja, vor dem haben wir schon eine Weile nichts mehr geguckt.
Wir skippen mal ein bisschen vor.
Also, wir haben uns einmal ein Video angeguckt
von einem startenden Retro-PC.
Und jetzt ist YouTube der Meinung,
Max, du möchtest dir jeden Tag ein Video
von einem startenden Retro-PC angucken.
Wo ist der Start-Sound?
Ich brauche den, ich brauche den, hier.
Brrrrm, bim, bim.
Du-du-du-du-du-du.
Ja, auf.
Warum macht es keinen Sound?
Jetzt.
Im Winter durch den Garten stelzen.
Wie gesagt, bisschen,
muss ein bisschen Viewtime,
muss ein bisschen Viewtime generaten.
Ich war gestern unterwegs
im Schnee
bei minus 4 Grad.
Und
kurz bevor ich wieder im Auto war,
habe ich mir gedacht, wir könnten eigentlich ein
Schneestelz-Video aufnehmen.
Aber da ging es den Berg runter, dass ich so
darauf achten musste, dass ich nicht gerutscht bin.
Ganz normal.
Nicht rennen, nee, ganz normal rumlaufen.
Nur, dass ich mir gedacht habe,
da kannst du jetzt nicht dein Handy rausholen
und aufs Handy gucken.
Aber ich habe 2-3 Minuten
so aufgenommen mit dem Handy.
Das kann ich theoretisch, wenn ich mal wieder,
wenn es mir mal wieder nach 10 Minuten
schwätzen ist,
kann ich das in den Hintergrund packen
und loopen für ein paar Minuten.
Ich muss mal kurz, oh, es ist
übelst kalt, Leute.
Minus 5,89.
Außentemperatur,
das ist auch eine super High-IQ-Anzeige
bei mir hier.
Außentemperatur, minus 5,89 Grad.
Gefühlt wie.
Minus 5,89 Grad.
Ja, no shit.
Dieses gefühlt wie ist bei mir immer exakt
die gleiche Anzeige, ob Wind oder nicht.
Normalerweise sollte es mit Wind ja weniger sein.
Deutsche Glasfaser, Achtung.
Telefonieoptionen.
Ich brauche keine Telefonie, ich habe mein Handy,
das reicht.
Das letzte Mal,
das ist tatsächlich schon ein paar Tage her.
Wann war das?
Wann war das
Glatteis?
Am Mittwoch?
Am Mittwoch, ne?
Dann war ich entweder Mittwochmorgen,
bevor Glatteis war.
Ne, Dienstag.
Dienstag war ich glaube ich zuletzt
rennen.
Also es ist echt schon eine Weile her.
Also da, hier war ich zuletzt.
Eins, zwei, drei, vier, das ist der fünfte Tag.
Aber ich kann nicht.
Es ist alles zugefroren und zugeschneit.
Ich könnte mich höchstens hier auf meinen
smarten Fahrradtrainer hocken.
Nochmal eine Runde.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
35 Monate High IQ
Increase.
Ja, bei mir ist auch seit
seit Mittwoch
ist hier alles
weiß im Endeffekt.
Also, was können wir uns denn jetzt angucken?
Was haben wir denn hier?
Neues smarten Fenster.
Ich will mal gucken, weil
ich bin da immer auf der Suche nach neuen
Smarthome-Geschichten.
... und generell im Nachrüst-Smarthome-Markt
bisher nicht oder nur mit Einschränkungen
und vielleicht...
Ich spule mal ein bisschen vor.
... auch schon Lösungen
von euch, wie ihr die
kleinsten Fenstersensoren
in den Fenster...
Wie funzt das jetzt hier?
Okay, fällt bei mir schon mal raus,
man muss irgendeine China-Chinesen-App
oder so verwenden von den
Smartphones.
Weiß ich nicht, Digga.
Da hätte ich schon wieder keinen Bock drauf.
Da hätte ich ja schon wieder keinen Bock drauf.
...
Dass das Ding...
Wisst ihr, mich nervt
das. Warum muss man
für alles, für jedes
Produkt irgendeine komische
schlecht gewartete, schlecht
gemachte Smartphone-App installieren?
Ja, wenn man viel
Xiaomi-Zeug hat,
da kann ich es in gewisser Weise irgendwie noch
vollziehen, weil dann auch wirklich alles mit der
gleichen App machen kannst und sowas.
Warum, liebe Hersteller?
Warum macht ihr es einem so schwer?
Kann man es nicht irgendwie
ordentlich einbinden?
Für irgendwelche normalen
Funkprotokolle. Ja, bei
Zigbee war das oftmals ja auch nicht gedacht.
Ging aber ohne Probleme.
Bei Z-Wave ist es von Haus aus vorgesehen.
Und ähm...
Bei Meta ist das auch kein
Problem, wobei Meta ja nicht das Funkprotokoll
ist. Sondern...
Die Logik oben drüber.
Es ist so kacke.
Das ist wie, wie der eine Typ, den wir ab und zu
mal geguckt haben auf YouTube,
der auf seinem...
Ey, wenn das Meta ist und sich einbinden lässt, dann ist
okay. Aber ich find's trotzdem kacke. Aber
mit eigenen Apps,
wenn sich's gescheit einbinden lässt, ist okay.
Wobei viele
Meta-Integrationen ja auch mit etwas exotischeren
Sensoren noch Probleme haben.
Zumindest, dann hast du am Endeffekt das
gleiche Problem wie der eine Typ, den wir öfters mal
auf YouTube da geguckt haben. Wenn du
in seinem Smartphone-Startbildschirm
gesehen hast, hat er erst mal
48 oder so verschiedene
Hersteller-Smart-Home-Apps
gehabt. Da hab ich mir auch immer gedacht, das hättest du...
Da bist du doch verrückt im Kopf.
Dann brauchst du im Endeffekt wahrscheinlich auch noch einen Account
für alle. Und nachdem es sich über's
Internet verbindet,
oder steuern lässt, am besten auch noch direkt
zwei Faktor-Authentifizierungen für alle Apps.
Dass sich irgendjemand einfach von außen dann
seinen Rasenmäher einschaltet.
Ich weiß nicht.
Das ist echt eines der großen Abfuck-
Themen, was Smartphones angeht.
Was ist das denn?
Ich glaube, ich kann mich daran sogar
noch erinnern. War das
nicht so, dass Steam
irgendein Shell-Skript
ausgeführt hat,
was dann
Recursive Delete
quasi gemacht hat, aber
nicht richtig geguckt hat? Also,
die haben Recursive Delete auf irgendeinen
relativen Pfad gemacht,
aber halt nicht geguckt, ob sie im richtigen
Verzeichnis sind. War das nicht das Problem?
Das kommt mir irgendwie bekannt vor.
Lass mal gucken.
... Insights, a series where we look at some of the most
interesting issues out there, from GitHub
to GitLab to proprietary issue trackers,
even to your favorite mailing lists.
We'll cover them all. We expect to produce
at least one episode of this series
every ten years, so buckle up as we dive
into today's issue from Valve.
The Linux version of Steam unintentionally
rm, rf-ing or recursively
force-deleting someone's entire
computer.
Ja, da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Moved local share Steam, run
Steam and delete everything on my system
owned by user. ... or recursively
force-deleting someone's entire computer.
Alter, 2015, man!
Wie gesagt, ich kann mich da dunkel noch
dran erinnern. Steam for Linux has changed
a lot since 2015, but here is
how it worked back in the day. You first
install Steam, after which you can
run the binary file called Steam
in the directory...
Das ist doch jetzt immer noch so, oder?
Als erstes musst du Steam installieren, um
Steam ausführen zu können. Wer hätte das
gedacht, Leute? ... user
bin to start the client.
This binary does not contain the full
Steam application, but invokes files
in the installation directory called
steam-roots in each user's home.
Before getting too deep, let's take a
high-level view of the Linux file system.
First, there is the root directory,
which, as we know, contains everything.
Then we see that user bin contains user
programs like steam, compared to
slash bin, which usually contains programs
essential for the operating system's
function. The home directory,
abbreviated as a tilde, and
located at slash home slash
name, works as you'd expect, and
is where each user stores all of their
stuff. In each user's home is the
steam... Ich muss klugscheißen!
Ich muss klugscheißen!
Tilde ist es natürlich nur,
wenn du als User 1 eingeloggt bist.
... all of their stuff. In each
user's home is the steam-root directory,
where steam installs itself and
stores its games. It also has an
important script called steam.sh,
which is what the steam binary invokes
to configure and launch steam.
After setting everything up, this script
will then invoke the main executable
called steam.exe.
All three of these...
Die Jungs, macht mir Angst manchmal. Warum?
Das ist unter Windows doch gar nicht so viel anders.
Unter Windows hast du auch... Du hast unter Windows
kein wirkliches root directory?
...
Das war glaube ich auch nicht ganz richtig,
was er da gezeigt hat...
...
Ja doch, er hat einfach nur
slash root, er hat slash und dann
Anführungszeichen root geschrieben.
Es ist ja, sagen wir mal so,
Windows hat kein reines root directory,
also slash. Bei Windows
hört es halt auf
Disk- oder Partitionsebene
auf. Aber im Prinzip
ist es da ähnlich. Du hast
c://users, da liegen deine
ganzen Dinger drinne. Du hast c://users, da liegen deine ganzen Dinger drinne.
Windows-Gedöns.
Du hast...
Früher gab es noch
Program Files
x86, und so komischen
Krempel. Da finde ich die
Sachen unter Linux tatsächlich sogar nachvollziehbarer.
Da finde ich die Sachen unter Linux tatsächlich sogar nachvollziehbarer.
...
Eine schöne Sache unter Linux ist, das war unter Windows lange Zeit
ja nicht so. Mittlerweile ist das
unter Windows zum größten Teil auch so...
In der regel reicht es, wenn du
ein Backup von deinem gesamten Home Directory
machst, dass du nichts vergisst.
Das war lange unter Windows nicht so, weil jeder alles überall hingehauen hat. Unter Windows ist es mittlerweile so. Es sei denn, natürlich, du benutzt andere Laufwerke und hast dann irgendwelche Sachen ausgelagert und so, da ist wieder was anderes.
Also ich habe zum Beispiel auch so, ich habe meinen Download-Ordner, also den hier nicht, aber bei meinem normalen User, ist der Download-Ordner auf einer Extra-Platte, weil der wird immer relativ schnell, relativ voll und warum sollte der auf meiner System-SSD sein? Da ist eh immer notorisch wenig Platz.
Genau, App-Data sichert man jetzt auch mit. Da ist eh genug Platz drauf. Äh, ist eh immer wenig Platz auf C.
Also ich bin mir sicher, ich bin mir sicher, genau in diesem Haus ist es gewesen.
Sim-Links oder Symbolic Links are just special files which point to the file or directory that they are linked to. These are kind of like shortcuts, except Sim-Links are completely transparent to the application layer as the operating system automatically resolves it to the target. So we can kind of see what Kevin was trying to do here. Move the Steam-Folder to a drive with better performance or storage capacity and create...
Das ist übrigens eine ganz normale Sache, macht man öfters unter Linux.
Also zum Beispiel...
Wo das bei uns auch im Business-Enterprise-Umfeld benutzt wird, ist für Java-Versionen zum Beispiel oder für Anwendungs-Versionen.
Du hast, du hast einen Ordner, da deployen die immer irgendwie 50-mal neue Versionen rein und du hast einen Link da drin, der immer auf die neueste Version zeigt.
Ja, du hast dann einen Ordner, du hast dann einen Ordner, da ist dann, keine Ahnung, hier, mkdir keckel, ja oder auch nicht, mkdir 0w.
Okay, wenigstens, wenigstens das nicht, ja.
Dann hast du dann hier sowas drin, hier, touch, keine Ahnung, Version 19, Version 5, Version 180, so, hast du da drin.
Und du hast eine, du hast eine Datei, ln-s, die zeigt halt auf die neueste Version, die heißt current oder so.
Und dann hast du hier immer, den Link drauf, so, und wenn jetzt, und wenn jetzt Version 181 deployed wird, dann linkst du das...
Muss man das vorher, echt, gab's nicht in Force oder sowas bei Link?
So, und jetzt hast du das wieder auf die neueste Version zeigen.
So, also das wird tatsächlich recht häufig benutzt, so, und jetzt hast du, ne, du weißt immer, wenn du was aufrufen willst, nimmst du immer das hier, aber du kannst hier halt sogar mehrere Versionen haben, um die wieder zu rollbacken.
Und du kannst dich halt drauf verlassen, dass das eben auf die neueste Version zeigt.
...to the sim link, so applications can still find that folder using the original path.
...then I launched Steam. It did not launch. It offered to let me browse, and still cannot find it when I pointed it to the new location. Steam crashed. I restarted it.
Ist das, Chat, ist das AI-generated, äh, Voice in dem Video?
...thought itself and everything looked great, until I looked and saw...
Es hört sich ein bisschen so an, ist es aber, glaube ich, nicht, weil der sich schon seit Jahren so anhört.
...that Steam had apparently deleted everything owned by my user recursively from the root's directory.
...including my three terabyte external drive I back everything up to.
...Dufy then followed up with a reply having encountered the same issue
This is terrible. I just...
...followed up with a reply having encountered this
I am impressed how calm you stay about this. This is terrible.
...I just lost my home directory. All I did was start Steam.
With Steam Debug XXI I will investigate this and report back.
"...small круtsch."
It's the same issue. This is terrible.
Kollege, du hättest doch einfach vorlesen können.
Von dem anderen, egal.
Oh, das ist immer problematisch.
Vor allem, es sind halt relative Pfade.
Und, ja gut.
Je nachdem, wie es gemacht ist, geht es nicht anders.
Das ist potenziell gefährlich.
Für die Steam-Root-Direktorie.
Eine Linie über dieser Kommande war der Kommentar schrecklich,
beziehungsweise, dass dies eine sehr schreckliche Operation war.
Bald genug schien TCM1911 mit einer Hypothese ein.
Diese Steam-Root-Variable muss irgendwie ein leerer String sein,
weil die RMRF-Argumente die Routes-Direktorie sind.
Nehmen wir einen kürzeren Blick auf Steam-Root.
Das ist in der Schlussfolgerung...
Okay, das ist Bash-Magic.
Lass mal kurz überlegen, ob ich dahinter komme, was es tut.
Ohne die Erklärung.
Also, das ist Sub-Shell.
Das ist genau, erzähl mal.
Das ist Sub-Shell.
Einsetzen hier in den String.
Das ist schön, dass es gequotet ist.
Vielleicht wäre es an der Stelle sogar besser, ungequotet.
Ne, wobei, das ist okay.
So, er geht CD.
So, jetzt kommt Bash-Magic.
0%.
Slash-Sternchen.
So, das hier ist Variable-Einsetzen.
Aber, was ist das?
Das ist anscheinend doch nicht Variable-Einsetzen.
0% Slash-Sternchen.
Ist 0% der letzte Pfad?
Ich habe seriously keine Ahnung, was das macht in Bash.
Das erste Argument.
Aber Argument 0 ist immer der eigene Pfad.
Wenn das geklappt hat.
Okay, aber ich sag mal so, den Fehler können wir wahrscheinlich auch schon erkennen.
Also sprich, wenn das hier erfolgreich war.
Also wenn das Wechseln in diesen Ordner erfolgreich war.
Dann gibt er den aktuellen Pfad aus.
Das heißt, wenn das hier nicht erfolgreich ist.
Dann ist der String 0.
Das heißt, danach hätte unbedingt eine Abfrage sein müssen.
If test-n.
Test-n.
Also not not empty.
Oder minus z für zero length string.
Und dann exit.
Shell-Skript.
Ich hab ein Herz für Shell-Skripts.
So gerade kleine Sachen oder irgendwelche Build-Commands und sowas ist einfach top.
And substitution.
Where the output of the commands run inside will substitute the expression and thus be assigned to Steam Root.
Und dann Output reinschreiben.
Well, it's what's going to be echoed or printed.
In this case.
In the environment working directory signified by this PWD.
Nur wenn das erste funktioniert hat.
The environment variable.
The working directory of the script is where it is run from, not where the script is located.
If you execute a script from the temp directory, the working directory returned by PWD will be temp.
So the strategy here is to first change directory or CD to the directory of the script and then print the working directory.
Ja nur, nur wenn das funktioniert hat.
We have another OS provided environment variable 0.
Which refers to the path of the script being executed.
Ah, Chat, ihr hattet recht.
Ihr hattet recht.
Das ist der eigene, der eigene Pfad, ja.
This percent signifies you want to remove the preceding pattern from the end of the preceding pattern.
Seriously, gibt es irgendjemand, der das aus dem Kopf weiß, was diese Bash-Syntax macht, man?
Ich mache schon relativ viel Bash-Skript, aber das ist echt komplett, auch für mich zu high IQ, äh.
String.
The pattern here is a forward slash followed by a wildcard.
So from the.
The preceding string, which is the path of the script, we start from the end and delete the first slash we see, followed by everything after it.
In this case, we delete.
Gibt es für sowas nicht filename?
Gibt es für sowas nicht genau ein Programm, was da irgendwelche Fehler.
Guck mal, es gibt doch filename.
Gehen wir hier irgendwie rein, keine Ahnung, vmchamp, so.
Filename, nee.
Nee, fuck, gibt es nicht.
Es gibt base.
Basename gibt es.
Ja, und das meine, das meine ich doch.
Das meine ich doch hier.
Ja.
Basename gibt es doch.
Sie können doch einfach basename verwenden.
Wobei, das ist wahrscheinlich nicht auf allen Systemen und was auch immer.
The name of the file leaving us with.
Äh, Chatke, Sekunde.
Moin Max, falls du dich noch an mich erinnern kannst.
Das werde ich gleich feststellen.
Moment.
Ja.
Ich habe nämlich gerade in deine Nachrichtshistorie reingeguckt.
Ähm.
Falls du dich noch an mich erinnern kannst.
Vor ein paar Monaten hatte ich ja gesagt, ich versuche eine neue Ausbildung zu bekommen.
Du hattest sogar einen Stellenanzeigen-Link gepostet.
Mit fast 28 Jahren habe ich eine Ausbildung im August als Fachinformatiker.
In der Anwendungsentwicklung bekommen.
Endlich raus.
Nice.
Ist das das, was du, warte mal, fuck.
MonkaS.
Ist das das, was du gepostet hast?
Wo du was gekriegt hast?
Oder woanders?
Der Jobvermittlungs-Champ.
Ja, aber schön, dass du das.
Du hast gefunden hast.
Ich habe es dir schon oft im Stream gesagt.
In der aktuellen Zeit.
Ist es so einfach wie noch nie zuvor, auch wenn man ein bisschen älter ist.
Nochmal was anders zu machen, wenn man keinen Bock mehr hat oder wenn man unbedingt was anderes machen will.
Ich war auch schon älter, als ich die Ausbildung gemacht habe.
Ich war nicht 28.
Ich war 21 oder so.
Und es ist auf jeden Fall sinnvoll.
Man weiß manchmal erst später, was einem gefällt.
Das ist halt das Ding, wenn man mit teilweise schon 16 anfängt, irgendeine Ausbildung zu machen, sich dann vorstellt, oh Mist, jetzt, nachdem ich die Ausbildung fertig habe und das vielleicht zwei, drei Jahre gemacht habe und dann feststelle, oh Mist, ich bin jetzt, keine Ahnung, ein paarundzwanzig.
Und man denkt sich dann so, ey, ich muss das mein restliches Leben machen.
Dann weiß man erst mal so richtig, auf was man sich eingelassen hat.
Und vielleicht stellt man dann fest.
Kein Bock drauf.
Und man ist einfach mit, sagen wir mal, 25 deutlich schlechter.
Schlauer, was das angeht, als mit 16, 17, 18.
Deswegen, ich finde das gut, wenn Leute das auch mal ein bisschen später dann feststellen und das machen.
Wie gesagt, ich habe auch meine Ausbildung später erst gemacht.
Also das, wo ich jetzt dran arbeite.
Wobei man sagen muss, das mit der Ausbildung, das weiß ich jetzt mal, hat jetzt auch nicht allzu viel miteinander zu tun.
Aber sonst wäre ich nicht da gelandet.
Ja, warum nicht?
Ja, das weiß man oftmals halt mit 17 noch nicht.
Okay, weiter.
Das habe ich vor 5 Minuten schon gesagt.
5.
already a steam process running so this is easily true next current status must not be set to this
magic exit code which is just a variable to ensure that this doesn't get stuck in an infinite loop
next the steam starting file must exist and it should exist since nothing has been done to the
steam config folder where it is located lastly it just confirms that the steam script is not
out of date which should be expected so the key condition which triggers reset steam is that this
installed bootstrap environment variable has to be an empty string which is the default value for
an unset variable before the reset steam check steam sh should run the main executable steam exe
which sets this variable to one after installing some bootstrap software the developers intended
for reset steam to trigger so ganz habe ich das jetzt aber mit dem summen den zusammenhang mit
dem summen link noch nicht gecheckt steam exe failed to do this indicating something went wrong
however in this case nothing was wrong
with steamy xe it was just executed with a path that is based on steam fruit which we've already
established is set incorrectly as an empty string due to the other bug so steam sh fails to run the
main executable at all since it has the wrong path the installed strap environment variable
is not exported and remains blank all the conditions of the if statement are met and then
reset steam is called so now we know how to trigger the bug run steam.sh inline with a shell like bash
this explains what happened to doofy who clearly ran steam.sh but how does this play into
caven's original account who only mentioned launching the main steam binary well a valve
employee had a hypothesis kevin first moved steam to an ntfs drive which being made for windows
doesn't play nice with the linux file system and would strip the executable bit in the version of
ubuntu used here this causes the steam binary to inevitably fail and crash as it cannot
execute anything in the drive then nobody in the version of ubuntu all the steam scripts and
binaries on the anniversary ach die haben kein plus x mehr dadurch dass er es auf ntfs kopiert hat
und jetzt ist das gefällt deswegen wurde reset steam ausgeführt used here okay das ist natürlich
inevitably fail and crash as it cannot execute anything in the drive then he gets really annoyed
bashed steam.sh and most importantly he gets amnesia and forgets he ever ran such a command
kevin replies that he only ran steam normally and he wasn't even sure if that line was the culprit
which makes sense given that from his perspective he never ran steam.sh furthermore he recalls he
may have mounted the drive with options to allow execution of all files which is reasonable given
that valve software themselves have tutorials to mount ntfs drives in this way and of course he is
still very calm and collected however the exact play-by-play actions cannot be confirmed since
the computer with all of its configurations was wiped so what now i suppose all we can do is guess
as i have my own never seen before theory to how this all happened so it all started on a stormy
wednesday evening when caven finished cooking up his lasagna also wenn ich eins gelernt habe dann
ist dass man sich nicht so sehr auf die erinnerung von usern verlassen kann was sie gemacht haben
heads to the computer room to work on his new gaming set ja und was man hätte probieren können
obwohl dateien gelöscht wurden man hätte mal gucken können ob man auf dem device also jetzt in dem fall
dann wahrscheinlich keine sda noch überreste findet von von der bash history zum beispiel und so was
da ist oftmals noch was da was man auslesen kann after setting everything up he attempts to run
steam but steam fails to run not because the ntfs drive did not add the executable bit but because
steven created the sim link incorrectly in home slash local rather than home slash logo slash
share where steam route is supposed to be this is a fairly easy typo to make as he made the same
mistake on the github issue he created he realizes his mistake and fixes the sim link creating it in
the proper folder and reruns steam while steam is still starting up he absentmindedly goes to
clean up the incorrect sim link because why not and forgets that he ever did so but unbeknownst to him
die meisten leute wissen nicht mal dass naja vielleicht vielleicht doch accidentally unlinked
the correct sim link instead in a stunning race condition he manages to do this in the literal
microseconds after steam.sh is invoked but before the assignment of steam route and since the sim
linked path no longer exists the directory change fails and steam route remains and we've already
established that if steam route is an empty string the bug will trip
to fix the bug various alterations to the steam route command such as using free link or der name
can guarantee a valid path is returned and checks can be added to verify steam route is a real path
furthermore bash has built-in options which make the shell exit when a command fails
so when the directory change or steam exe execution fails the script immediately ends
benutzt jemand von euch regelmäßig z minus e in bash skripten ich fange immer damit an
das immer direkt einen meine bash skripts aber ich werfe es dann irgendwann wieder raus weil
es mir zu ätzend ist instead of proceeding with buggy behavior these are what ended up being the
actual fix but many disagreed that this was enough some suggested to write all the scripts in a real
language like python or pro or check for da kannst du genauso gut misst programmieren typical linux
directories look up files from an internal database and only remove known files not writing
amateur our code never use rmrf using a database that only removes known files not writing amateur
our code never use rmrf using a database that only removes known files not writing amateur our code
never use rmrf using a database that only removes known files not writing amateur our code never use rmrf
empty file as a marker don't use the wildcard you should just lock this thread just don't delete
user data by the way here's my public domain script that has that's that's that's the best
das ist das ist die absolute forehead die sollen es einfach so machen wie wir im stream immer
und immer first try funktioniert funktionieren perfekte sachen programmieren dann braucht man
keine doku keine tests und keine kommentare
user data by the way here's my public domain script that has my preferred fix valve has no idea
how to linux has this problem been fixed it's still happening question mark you know we could talk for
centuries about the ideal way to fix this but sometimes you don't need to achieve perfection
anyways it's been like nine years and the issue hasn't resurfaced for anyone except this guy but
he didn't provide further evidence so we can mark this issue resolved see you in the next issue of
issues insights jetzt wissen wir bescheid
oder auch nicht so youtube was gibt's denn sonst noch hier ex apple editor
das ist auch ein trend der wieder mal aufkommen dürfte ich würde gerne
ich würde gerne neue el risitas videos sehen da gab es ja ein paar mega lustige aber
die sachen sind sind leider nicht mehr so populär also ich muss echt sagen youtube ist ziemlich hart
da hinterher mir meine eigenen videos zu empfehlen
aber view time leute leute hier ist der max und view time ich lasse einfach weiterlaufen
übrigens ich habe letztens mit herr endpunkt teams nicht teams was habe ich denn in discord
geschwätzt war für eine stunde während mmo kreisel client aber na es läuft wartet mal
der erkennt doch wenn es in einem anderen tab läuft und keinen fokus hat dann muss ich mein
eigenes video auflassen jetzt okay ja ich habe letztens mit der endpunkt tatsächlich eine runde
discord telefoniert ich habe letztens mit der endpunkt tatsächlich eine runde discord telefoniert
telefoniert der ist jetzt bei einer bank gelandet in frankfurt wäre das gedacht irgendwie früher
oder später landen in frankfurt alle mal bei einer bank und ist dort jetzt irgendwie product owner
für irgendeine anwendung keine ahnung also der hat's auch hat die kurve gekriegt und macht jetzt
fett stonks die stocks macht er nicht aber genug kohle und wenn das nach diesem super schlechten
start herr endpunkt geschafft hat können das alle packen wenn sie sich mühe geben
dann geht's weiter zum nächsten tipp 2 ist die diverse
jetzt schauen wir mal was es da kann man wirklich sagen röhrfisch dass du mittlerweile mitbekommen
dass mittlerweile schon im boards gibt er explizit mitbekommen habe ich das nicht aber das ist ja eine
sache die ich auch schon seit jahren erzählt habe dass das früher oder später kommen wird und das
externer externer input auch kommen wird also sprich sachen die dann wirklich
dass zumindest ein PC denkt, es käme über die Maus.
Weil klicken tut da nichts.
Das ist nicht so, als ist da so ein kleiner Vogel,
der mit dem Schnabel so auf die Taste...
Also ich habe schon Konstruktionen gesehen,
wo Leute mit einem ESP oder einem Arduino
quasi eine Maus emuliert haben,
damit gecheatet haben,
dass dann es quasi aussah wie direkt der Input.
Und auch schon Bilderkennung und sowas.
Und das funktioniert erstaunlich gut.
Und hast du schon von dem AI-Monitor von MSI gehört,
der bald kommt?
Nein, das kenne ich nicht.
Zeig mal.
Was?
Nee, nee, das kenne ich tatsächlich nicht.
MSI AI-Monitor.
Next-Gen QLED-Monitor-Lineup.
Das da?
UX.
Ja, aber Schatten.
Das da, hä?
Hier.
PC Games Hardware.
Okay, die wissen, wovon sie reden.
Ein Riesenstand von MSI hier auf der CES 2024.
Es gibt Massig...
Übrigens, Leute, soll ich euch mal was zeigen?
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Ihr werdet es nicht glauben,
aber nach über 10 Jahren
bin ich auf Twitter anblockt worden von MSI.
Geil, oder?
Endlich.
Ich kann wieder mit meinem Twitter-Account
MSI Deutschland aufmachen.
Ich weiß bis heute nicht, warum ich...
Ich weiß es nicht, Leute.
Ich habe keine Ahnung,
warum die mich je geblockt...
Ich habe keinen Schimmer.
Ob es 7 neue...
Habe ich mir sagen lassen.
Die Messe kommt einfach nicht ohne ein bestimmtes Passwort.
Die Namen der Monitore sind auch wieder geil.
MEG-321-Urx-Kudel-OLED.
Das ich eigentlich noch nie gehört habe.
Man nennt es AI.
Und das ist auch in den Monitoren.
Habe ich mir sagen lassen.
Ich habe noch überhaupt keine Ahnung,
welche Specs und das alles ist.
Und dafür ist hier...
Und den brauche ich unbedingt,
dass ich League of Legends spielen kann.
Wolf von MSI, der uns das alles erzählt.
Das ist ein besonderer Monitor.
QD-OLED.
Genau.
Mit AI.
Was er ja sonst noch...
Und Spiegel der Oberfläche.
Ja, das erzählt der Wolf.
Geht super leicht von der Zunge, ja.
Ja, genau.
Du hast ja gerade schon gesagt,
wir haben mehrere Monitore vorgestellt.
MEG-321-Urx-Kudel-OLED.
Alter.
Ja, sind bei uns alle Schienen auf OLED-Monitor gestellt.
Sechs neue OLED-Monitore.
Plus...
OLED-Monitore sind auch porke.
Das sind noch nicht mal die einzigen,
die wir vorgestellt haben.
Aber das ist auf jeden Fall das Glanzstück.
Ein ganz besonderer,
weil dieser Monitor hat einen AI-Chip verbaut.
Das Stück nennt sich MEG-321-Urx-Kudel-OLED.
Super, super klangvoller Name.
Easy aussprechbar.
Tatsächlich der erste Monitor,
der einen solchen AI-Chip verbaut hat.
Vielleicht erinnert man sich daran,
früher hatten wir mal einen Monitor im Angebot.
Das hatte eine GameSense-Bar.
Das hatte auch eine LED-Leiste hier unten drin.
Aha.
Die konnte bei bestimmten Spielen
die Lebensenergie-Anzeige von den Spielen widerspiegeln.
Diese Bar hier ist ein bisschen anders,
denn der AI-Chip greift nicht auf die Spieldaten zu,
sondern der greift auf die Bilddaten zu.
Das heißt, der scannt tatsächlich das ganze Bild,
in dem Fall von League of Legends,
und kann dann erkennen, wo hier die Lebensenergie-Leiste ist
und spiegelt das hier unten noch einmal wieder.
Das Besondere daran ist,
dass er sich theoretisch auch auf jedes andere Spiel anwenden lässt.
Das heißt, dieser AI-Chip, dadurch, dass es echtes AI ist...
Aber wo jetzt...
Jetzt mal...
Ich verstehe es noch nicht so ganz.
Wo ist der Vorteil von einer LED-Leiste,
die die Lebensenergie anzeigt,
versus die Lebensenergie-Anzeige?
Bis jetzt haben sie nicht gecheckt, was so geil ist.
Der kann also Prozentanzeigen überall auf dem Bildschirm erkennen,
sobald er entsprechend trainiert ist,
und kann dann diese Bar hier unten die Lebensenergie anzeigen lassen.
Das gerade hier ist jetzt nur ein Video.
Das ist also eine frühe Demo-Version.
Wann wir genau die finale Version haben,
das weiß ich noch nicht ganz genau.
Aber es wird auf jeden Fall, ich denke,
so in Q2, Q3 für uns langsam spruchreich werden.
Kann die AI nur Lebensenergie-Leisten rausfischen
oder auch sonstige Funktionen oder Daten vom Spiel?
Die hat durchaus auch weitere Funktionen.
Also es gibt weitere Funktionen.
Erst mal in der frühen Version kann sie erst mal diese Energie-Leisten erkennen.
Allerdings, man sieht es bei dem Spiel hier auch,
man hat hier mehr als eine Leiste,
eins für Lebensenergie, eins für Mana.
Und theoretisch lässt sich das auch ganz einfach adaptieren auf die Mana-Leiste.
Du könntest auch, wenn du beispielsweise jetzt Diabo,
spielen würdest, wo du ja so eine Sphäre hast,
da kann der auch quasi 100% und 0% erkennen.
Und dann kann sich die Bar ebenfalls dann anpassen und das anzeigen.
Das ist allerdings jetzt noch nicht der aktuelle Stand.
Das muss alles noch antrainiert werden.
Ja, und welche Spiele, für welche Spiele das dann einfacher
und für welche es schwieriger wird, das steht jetzt noch nicht fest.
Ja, also das ist noch so ein früher Zustand.
Es gibt allerdings noch eine weitere Anwendung,
die nichts mit der Lebensenergie zu tun hat.
Und das nennt sich momentan AI SkySight.
Die AI kann hier, wie gesagt, Bilddaten werden abgegriffen.
Kann hier auf die Mini-Map zugreifen, die erkennt, wo die Mini-Map ist
und sieht hier auch, wo sich die Gegner befinden.
Und diese Information spiegelt sich dann auf dem großen Bildschirm wieder.
Man sieht das jetzt an...
Ah, okay, da geht's jetzt schon in die Richtung, wo ich sagen würde,
da kann man drüber diskutieren, ob das erlaubt sein sollte oder nicht.
Weil das andere zeigt ja im Endeffekt nur an,
was du eh schon, ja, auf einen Blick siehst.
Du siehst zwar Theorien,
aber theoretisch Movement auf der...
Ich bin mir noch nicht ganz sicher, was jetzt kommt, ja.
Du kannst theoretisch Movement auf der Mini-Map auch sehen,
aber irgendwann ist es halt so, dass ein gewisses Skill-Level
bei Games halt auch ist, alles mitzubekommen,
was das Game dir an Informationen liefert.
Und wenn das, wenn der Monitor beispielsweise erkennt auf der Mini-Map,
dass ein Gegner aus dieser Richtung, sagen wir mal, kommt,
du aber gerade durch andere Aktivitäten im Game
und du es selbst so jetzt nicht sehen würdest,
dann ist es schon ein Vorteil, ja.
... manchen Punkten.
Ich müsste hier das Video an bestimmten Stellen anhalten.
Moment, da war es gerade.
Dieses Zeichen, dieses Ikon hier, das gehört nicht zum eigentlichen Spiel,
sondern...
Also, wenn Sachen Overlays zeichnen, es sind ja keine Overlays,
das ist wie...
Dafür gibt es noch kein Wort, weil es das bisher nicht gab.
Es sind ja keine Overlays.
Overlays wäre ja irgend so ein Windows-Ding, was ein Fenster drüber malt.
Es ist quasi...
ein Hardware-Overlay, könnte man...
könnte man sagen.
Ein Hardware-Overlay.
Ach, das ist schwierig.
Also, fraglich, was es bringt, wirklich.
Aber das ist Cheaten.
Je nachdem...
Selbst...
Ich würde es ja nicht mal davon abhängig machen,
ob es jetzt so super sinnvoll ist oder nicht.
Es rendert dir...
Es rendert...
Ist auch das falsche Wort.
Es rendert nicht.
Ich sage jetzt aber trotzdem.
Es rendert dir in das Game...
oder es zeigt dir...
die Spielinformationen an,
die so in einem Competitive-Multiplayer-Spiel nicht verfügbar sind.
Das ist...
Das ist Cheaten.
Auf der anderen Seite könnte man auch argumentieren,
dass auch, wenn du Path of Exile spielst,
die 3000 Zusatzprogramme, die du verwenden musst,
um richtig gut durchzukommen, auch Cheaten sind.
Allerdings ist Path of Exile kein Competitive-PVP-Spiel
und wo es auch nicht auf Reactions oder so ankommt
oder auf...
Aber die Tools helfen dir bei Path of Exile im Gameplay nicht.
Die machen dir andere Sachen leichter.
Deswegen, es ist schwierig.
Also, ich würde sagen, in dem Fall ist die Grenze zum Cheaten schon überschritten.
In dem Kontext von dem Game.
Das ist Teil der AI.
Die hat jetzt festgestellt, in dieser Richtung befindet sich ein Gegner,
hat sie über die Minimap gescannt.
Das ist Cheaten.
Und zeigt dann eben an, in welche Richtung man laufen muss
oder in welche Richtung man vielleicht auch ausweichen möchte.
Das ist ungefähr ähnlich zu vergleichen mit, du wirst gecoacht.
Stell dir vor, du kannst ja Coaching kaufen für League of Legends
und du hast einen Coach, der dir zuguckt beim Gameplay
und sagt, hey, guck mal, oben ist ein Gegner.
So ungefähr ist das.
Und das ist jetzt vielleicht nicht Cheaten im klassischen Sinne,
aber es ist schon, sagen wir mal, ein externer Vorteil,
wo aus meiner Sicht die Grenze zum Cheaten überschritten ist.
Das ist also eine zusätzliche Hilfe.
Ja, also man muss natürlich sehen, wenn man jetzt kompetitiv spielt,
dann ist das vielleicht nicht die faireste Methode,
aber es ist auf jeden Fall eine Anwendung, die man ohne...
Schön, dass er das so sagt.
...AI, ohne dieses Screenscanning von der AI nicht hätte.
Also noch ist es kein...
Kann man das mit einem Crosshair vergleichen in einem Shooter?
Nicht wirklich, oder?
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie du dir das meinst,
aber das zeigt dir halt Sachen präsenter an,
die du im Eifer des Gefechts so nicht mitmachst.
Was du nicht mitbekommen hättest, höchstwahrscheinlich.
Das ist ein bisschen...
Okay, machen wir mal was, machen wir mal einen Vergleich.
Stellt euch vor...
Stellt euch vor, ihr spielt CS.
So, stellt euch vor, ihr spielt CS.
Und...
Ihr lauft hier vorbei, ganz schnell.
Ihr lauft ganz schnell hier vorbei.
So schnell, dass ihr nicht checken könnt, was hinter der Tür ist.
Aber nur weil ihr das nicht checken könnt, was hinter der Tür ist,
wenn ihr das nicht checken könnt,
kann das natürlich eine Bildanalyse trotzdem checken.
Stellt euch vor, ihr zieht einfach nur ganz kurz die Kamera da drüber,
und das Ding erkennt innerhalb von einer Millisekunde,
was ihr gehirntechnisch überhaupt nicht verarbeiten könnt,
da war ein Gegner, und zeigt euch dann einen Marker auf dem Overlay an,
dass ihr gerade einen Gegner übersehen habt.
Das ist Cheaten.
Und sowas ähnliches ist das in League of Legends auch, ja?
Stellt euch vor, der Typ wäre hier...
Ganz kurz zu sehen, für einen Frame bei 240 FPS,
ihr zieht da wirklich nur kurz rüber, rennt vorbei,
ihr habt keine Chance, ihn zu sehen,
und euer Monitor sagt, ne, Moment mal, links, da ist ein Gegner gewesen.
Also, das ist schon...
Man kann jetzt sagen, es ist kein Cheaten,
weil es sind ja Informationen, die tatsächlich das Game angezeigt hat.
Oder man kann sagen, es ist Cheaten,
weil es so in dem Zusammenhang nicht möglich gewesen wäre, das zu erkennen.
So ein drittes Auge quasi, ja?
Also, für mich ist die Grenze zum Cheaten tatsächlich bei sowas überschritten.
Cheaten.
Noch ist es kein Cheaten, nein.
Wie man das dann verwendet, muss natürlich jeder für sich sein.
Ja, ja, genau, MSI.
Das ist die gleiche Sache wie...
Ja, Moment, also...
Ich lade auch nur Sicherheitskopien hoch.
Oder ich lade auch nur Sicherheitskopien runter,
falls meine CD verkratzt ist.
Aber wir wissen, okay, Ihnen ist auch klar, in welche Richtung das Ganze geht.
Aber ein weiterer Punkt, den man daran sieht, ist,
es ist vollkommen egal, ob wir das jetzt als Cheaten identifizieren oder nicht.
Und es ist auch vollkommen egal, ob MSI der Erste ist, der das macht.
Es wird gemacht werden.
Und sei es, wenn es nicht MSI ist...
Also, das ist, was ich bei der ganzen AI-Diskussion immer lustig finde,
wenn sie dann ankommen mit, das Erste, was ich in Deutschland gehört habe zum Thema AI,
war so eine typisch deutsche Sache.
Als das ganz frisch war mit Jet-GPT und alle noch begeistert waren,
das Erste, was ich von irgendeinem gehört habe, ist so,
oh, wir brauchen einen Ethikrat für KI und sowas.
Mit irgendwelchen Räten und Sachen, Gründen,
sind wir in Deutschland ja eh immer superschnell unterwegs.
Man wird das nicht aufhalten können.
Egal, wie kacke man manche Entwicklungen findet, das wird kommen.
Und ob MSI das jetzt macht oder irgendwelche Hackermans,
wo du dir dann die Zusatzsachen kaufen kannst für dein System,
ist egal, es passiert auf jeden Fall.
Das heißt, das ist ein Thema, womit sich Gamer und Spielehersteller
jetzt auseinandersetzen müssen, was man damit macht.
Kommen wird das eh.
Wir empfehlen, nicht zu cheaten, wenn man kompetitiv spielt.
Absolut, okay.
Vielleicht noch ein paar andere Randdaten zum Monitor.
Also, abgesehen von der AI, hat der ganz ordentliche Specs, sag ich mal.
Ich sehe da 4K, also UHD,
mit 240 Hz, mit OLED halt niedrig gepaart.
Ja, also OLED und 240 Hz gepaart ist natürlich schon extrem nice.
Der Monitor wirbt damit, dass er keinen Lüfter braucht.
Aber wir wissen mittlerweile, spätestens seit ein paar Jahren,
als Asus damit angefangen hat,
dass Monitore mit Lüfter eine ganz normale Sache ja ist,
zu sein scheinen mittlerweile.
Sekunde, warte mal, ich muss mal kurz hier grad ein Kabel...
Ach, was ist das hier?
So, locker über 1000.
Ja, ja, denke ich auch.
Lüfter im Monitor, ja.
Gab es bei Asus.
Asus hatte Lüfter in Monitoren.
Ich bin mal gespannt.
Also, ich kann das jetzt schwer einschätzen,
wie nützlich es wirklich am Ende ist.
Potential sehe ich da für ziemlich viele unfaire Sachen.
Hm.
Du wirst keinen Bann dafür kassieren.
Das ist ja nicht detectable wirklich.
Naja, doch, doch.
Also, nee, nee, sagen wir mal so.
Vordergründig ist es erst mal detectable.
Man kann es natürlich bestimmt irgendwie auslesen,
was für ein Monitortyp attached ist.
Aber das kann man wahrscheinlich easy as fuck verschleiern.
Da gibt es dann irgendwelche Zwischenstecker,
da kannst du es nicht machen.
Also, das ist eine Sache, die nicht wirklich detectable ist.
Realistisch gesehen.
Du kannst es nicht einfach bannen.
Das wird schwierig, das wird schwierig, ja.
Wir werden eh ein neues Wettrüsten erleben
aus Cheatern und Anti-Cheat.
Beide Seiten KI-gestützt.
Sieht man ja jetzt schon.
240 Hertz mit OLED halt niedrige Reaktionszeiten.
Ansonsten, ja, denke ich mal, guter, üblicher OLED,
so wie man ihn heutzutage kennt.
Ich wette, das wird absolut nicht billig werden.
Ja, da wäre meine Frage nur noch, was kostet sowas?
Wann kommt es auf den Markt?
Also, erst mal, das hier ist unsere MEG-Serie.
Das ist für uns die Enthusiasten-Serie
und die ist immer hochpreisiger als die anderen Produktgruppen,
die wir haben.
Natürlich hat das seinen Preis.
Was ist OLED Care 2.0?
Ah, Screen Burn-In, okay.
Aktuell rechnen wir mit 1299, vielleicht auch etwas mehr.
Das können wir noch nicht sagen,
weil das hier nur die Schätzpreise für den globalen Markt sind.
Und ob das in Deutschland dann zum gleichen Preis bei uns ankommen kann,
das wissen wir einfach noch nicht.
Es ist allerdings so, wir haben, wie ich eben ja schon sagte,
ziemlich viele OLED-Monitore vorgestellt
und davon auch einige in etwas niedrigeren Preiskategorien.
7.000, 8.000, 9.000, 10.000, 11.000, 12.000.
27 Zoll mit etwas kleinerer Ausstattung,
ohne AI-Chip und so weiter und so fort.
Also da gibt es teilweise auch Modelle,
die sind dann für um 800 Euro schon zu haben
und teilweise auch wahrscheinlich über die Zeit weniger.
Das heißt, es wird verfügbar für jeden sein,
der wirklich OLED haben möchte.
Cool, alles klar. Schauen wir weiter, oder?
Ja, gerne.
Es gibt, wie gesagt, insgesamt sieben Monitore
hier auf der CES aufgestanden.
Okay, jetzt ist das Deutsch vorbei, oder?
Ich stelle mir jetzt nicht alle vor, keine Angst,
ich bin immer gespannt, wie sich das entwickelt.
Wir haben unten in der Videobeschreibung trotzdem die Zusammensetzung.
Ein rasantes Thema.
High-IQ-Chat.
Ah, guck mal, mein Video ist fast fertig durchgelaufen, nice.
YouTube begins new wave of slowdowns for users with Adblock enabled.
Oh, YouTube, geht mir nicht auf den Sack, Mann.
Ich mache YouTube-Videos, ich bringe euch Kohle.
Ich habe einen Premium-Account, geht mir nicht auf den Sack, Mann.
Lasst mich doch einfach YouTube-Videos gucken hier.
Hm, ich will ja auch nicht eingeloggt sein.
Ich will ja auch nicht eingeloggt sein vor meinem Streaming-Account.
Sind schon nervig, oder?
Switch from Docker to Portman.
Red hat Zeug da.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Ich wollte mir noch die ganze Zeit schon mal hier irgendwie das ...
Was ist denn hier?
Wir hatten doch hier das da.
Jeden Tag League of Legends.
So viel Geld verdient ein ...
Geld verdient mit eSport als Coach.
Das wollte ich mir schon seit einer Woche oder seit zwei ...
Jetzt kommen wir zu den guten Sachen.
Der Fight war sehr nice gespielt von dir.
Sehr nice.
Damit kann man Geld verdienen?
Exzellent.
Mit Computer spielen?
Das kann doch nicht sein.
Ja gut, das sagen irgendwelche 90-jährigen Ultra-Boomer.
Ich meine, alle anderen haben das sogar in Deutschland schon gecheckt,
dass man ...
Okay, wobei, nee.
Nee, nee, nee.
Ich muss ...
Das stimmt nicht, was ich sagen will.
Wir haben das vielleicht schon gecheckt.
Und vielleicht die einen oder anderen der etwas älteren Generation
haben das schon gecheckt.
Aber wenn ich mir die Leute in Deutschland so ...
Nee, die haben das noch nicht gecheckt.
Wenn jetzt League of Legends einfach den Bach runtergeht
und es niemand mehr guckt, habe ich keinen Job mehr.
Hey, ich bin der Max.
Ich gehe davon aus, wenn das wirklich den Bach runtergeht,
der ist da so im eSports-Game drin,
dann hat er das nächste Game am Start.
Wie viele Tabs ich aufhabe, ich habe da Tabs auf,
ich habe da Tabs auf, ich habe da Tabs auf.
Und ich habe in meiner Feier Tabs auf.
Ich bin 29.
Irgendwo muss der RAM ja hin.
Ach, das ist Max.
eSports-Coach und arbeite ...
Fuck, Leute.
Facebook.
xLeague.
Für die eSports-Player-Foundation eine sportliche Leitung.
Aber dann kann er sich ja nur auskennen.
Trainingscamp in Österreich.
Es gehört einfach zum Alltag eines Pro-Gamers auch dazu,
dass man körperlich fit ist.
Richtig.
Jetzt wird dann erst mal gefrühstückt.
Dann gebe ich erst mal einen Vortrag über Sportpsychologie.
Und ja, dann gibt es Coaching.
Wir sind hier im Bootcamp der eSports-Player-Foundation.
Das ist eigentlich eine Art Trainingslager für eSportler.
Und ja, jetzt fangen wir dann mit einer Präsentation an.
Die nennt sich Sportpsychologie im eSport.
Es ist ein sehr, sehr wichtiger Punkt,
weil vieles im Sport ist halt einfach eine Kopfsache.
Ist man jetzt wirklich da?
In dem Moment kann man die 100 Prozent gerade bringen.
Muss gecrinet werden.
eSports-Coach ist eigentlich, ja, ähnlich wie im traditionellen Sport,
ein Trainer, der für eine Mannschaft oder für eine Organisation arbeitet
und Spieler ausbildet im eSports.
Die eSports-Player-Foundation ist eine Non-Pro-Foundation,
die zur Talentförderung im eSports da ist.
Wir scouten junge Talente und versuchen, die so gut wie möglich zu machen
und sie dann auf ihrem Weg als Profi-Gamer zu begleiten.
Also die EPF ist einerseits durch Sponsoren gedeckt.
Schönes Büro haben sie.
Andererseits haben wir jetzt zum Beispiel auch eine Kooperation
mit dem Land Nordrhein-Westfalen.
Ich hoffe einfach, dass wir irgendwann soweit sind,
dass es auch eine staatliche Förderung wird,
weil dann sind wir nicht mehr so angewiesen
auf das Land Nordrhein-Westfalen zu sein.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Wir sind nicht mehr so angewiesen auf wirtschaftliche Sponsoren.
So, einmal kurz zuhören bitte.
Ich habe das Thema gewählt,
worüber ich meine Bachelorarbeit geschrieben habe.
Um folgende psychologische Faktoren geht es heute.
Mentale Stärke, Emotionen und Körperhaltung.
Einfach mal, was fällt euch zu diesen drei Begriffen ein?
Einfach mal Hand hoch.
Zur Körperhaltung fällt mir ein,
dass ich sicherlich immer die super ergonomischste Körperhaltung ever habe,
wenn ich vor dem PC sitze.
Und dass ich mal wieder meine Schultern nach hinten bewegen kann.
Jetzt darf mal eine Person nach vorne kommen
und sich hier draufstellen.
Einfach draufstellen.
Wie schwierig ist die Aufgabe?
Geht.
Nicht sonderlich schwer.
Wie schwierig wird die Aufgabe,
wenn wir jetzt das in 200 Meter Höhe machen?
Extrem schwer.
Ich würde nicht meine Hände da oben unbedingt reinstecken jetzt.
Im Sport, also du darfst wieder runtergehen
und darfst dich wieder hinsetzen.
Genauso ist es im Sport.
Im Unterschied zwischen Wettkampf und Training.
Ich denke E-Sport.
Das ist ein mega guter Vergleich.
Oder?
Okay, der hat Ahnung, was er macht.
Den finde ich nice.
Das ist ein echt guter Vergleich.
Es ist ein Riesenunterschied.
Es ist auch ein Unterschied,
das kannst du auf ganz viele Situationen übertragen.
Es ist auch ein Unterschied, ob ich jetzt hier sitze
und mit 250 Leuten labere
oder ob ich vor euch stehen würde
und würde mich alle anklotzen.
Und ich müsste jetzt irgendwas von mir geben.
Das wäre auch schon ein Unterschied.
Oder ich habe es auch in Overwatch gemerkt.
Das ist ein easy Ding.
Wir haben so viele Scrims,
wie es ja so geil heißt,
so viele Übungsmatches gespielt.
Es war alles easy.
Aber sobald du irgendeinen Cup
oder irgendwas ein bisschen
größeres gespielt hast,
warst du nervös.
Das ist ein echt guter Vergleich.
Sport unterscheidet sich jetzt in der Hinsicht
nicht so vom traditionellen Sport.
Im Endeffekt sind wir alle Werbeplattformen.
Also wenn jetzt das Land NRW
Geld in uns reinsteckt
und wir den besten League-of-Legends-Spieler
der Welt rausbringen,
dann hat das natürlich eine Strahlkraft.
Oh, NRW, gutes, fortschrittliches Land.
Und dann erst mal
die Anmeldung per Fax geschickt.
Wir machen jetzt gleich eine Coaching-Session
mit Sari.
Die ist ein sehr guter Mann.
Sie ist ein sehr guter Mann.
Sie ist die Supporterin
aus unserem Nachwuchs-Team
von den DKB Diamonds.
Mein Wochenziel für diese Woche ist es,
out of no vision zu kommen
und die Gegner zu überraschen mit meinem Angriff
und dann halt eine fette Kombo zu machen.
Wie ich so keinen Plan habe
von League-of-Legends-Fachjargon.
Sari ist 19 Jahre alt.
Wir haben sie letztes Jahr
aufgenommen in die Förderung.
Sie hat sich in der Zeit eigentlich
schon sehr, sehr krass entwickelt.
Und ich möchte sie eigentlich auch,
wie sie will,
die Gegner angreifen
aus der Richtung,
wo sie sie nicht sehen können.
Also quasi nicht so telegraphen,
wo jetzt was passiert,
sondern eher out of vision dann.
Also...
Ich halte sehr große Stücke auf sie
und deswegen nehme ich mir auch
sehr viel Zeit dafür,
sie besser zu machen.
Dann spielt sie jetzt,
dann gucken wir da kurz drüber
und dann gehen wir zum Sport.
Was sagst du generell zu dem Game?
Die Lane war scheiße.
Also ich glaube,
der Lane hat sich nur angefühlt,
als hätte man nur so ein kurzes Win.
Lane ist das einzige, was ich weiß
in LoL. Was ist es, Mann?
Hier musst du schneller
quasi einfach auf den Ezreal tummeln.
Untertitel hier oder was?
Nee.
To be honest, wenn ihr da nur
einen kurzen Trade spielt,
dann stirbt dein AD Carry auch nicht.
Okay, das habe ich verstanden.
Das habe ich tatsächlich verstanden
als Null-Lol-Kenner.
Das heißt, wenn ihr da nur
einen kurzen Trade spielt, dann...
Also, Trade ist...
Okay, pass mal auf, Leute.
Ich versuch das mal für die Leute,
die...
Ihr müsst mir sagen, ob ich richtig liege.
Ihr müsst mir sagen, ob ich richtig liese.
Also, Trade ist ja immer...
Gibt es ja in jedem Game,
ist ein Fight und Trade ist so was wie,
ich kill einen
und dadurch werde ich von einem anderen
gekillt, weil ich out of position bin.
Da haben wir getradet, so im Endeffekt.
So.
Die haben getradet und...
Moment.
To be honest, wenn ihr da nur
einen kurzen Trade spielt, dann...
Okay, kurzer Trade, also kurzer...
Ja, was auch immer da gefaltet wird.
Dann stirbt dein AD Carry auch nicht.
Okay, dann stirbt der AD Carrier.
Das heißt, AD Carrier, das kenne ich.
Das ist LoL-Fachjargon.
Das ist...
Auto Attack Damage oder so was.
Auto...
Damage?
Ach, fuck, ich hab's vergessen.
Das sind im Endeffekt...
Das ist da, wo das Wort Carry näher kommt.
Das sind...
Das sind die Typen, die das Gegnerteam killen.
Im Endeffekt.
Um die du dich die ganze Zeit kümmern musst.
Weil die Early Game übel sacken
und wenn du als Support
und generell das gesamte Team aber
schön deinen AD Carrier
carryen, dann carryet der dich im Endgame.
Excellent Erklärung, oder?
Jetzt habt ihr alles verstanden.
War das richtig?
LOL Checker Mans im Chat?
Ist fein, dann kriegt ihr probably Flash und Exhaust raus.
Okay, wie man Flash und Exhaust rauskriegt,
hab ich keine Ahnung.
Der Fight war sehr nice gespielt von dir.
Hättest du noch theoretisch gesehen hier hingehen können?
Hier kannst du auch hingehen, ja.
Also mit meinen Eltern gab's am Anfang
sehr, sehr viel Zwist, muss ich sagen.
Die haben mir die ganze Zeit gesagt,
du machst dir dein Leben kaputt.
Ja, das ist ja immer so.
Das meinen die auch nicht böse,
das muss man auch mal sehen.
Die wissen's nicht besser.
Ich mein, man darf ja auch nicht vergessen,
es gibt viele Leute, die träumen davon,
im E-Sports ihr Geld zu verdienen
und da klappt das nicht.
Da muss schon ein gefunkener Talent
Ausdauer zur richtigen Zeit
am richtigen Ort, wie bei vielem halt.
Die Eltern meinen das ja nicht böse.
Ich kann nur dran erinnern,
meine Mutter hat mich damals auch
zu einer Berufsberatung im Arbeitsamt
gezwungen
und bei der Berufsberatung
kam raus,
ich soll was mit Holz lernen,
nicht Computer und IT.
Als ich dann bei Hertha BSC war,
war sie wirklich fein damit.
Ja, okay, das sieht jetzt schon sehr serious aus.
Ich glaube,
du kannst damit dein Leben leben.
Okay, nice, danke.
Als nächstes ist wieder Sport an der Reihe.
Vor dem Essen,
heute gibt es ein bisschen Dehnen und Yoga,
einfach so, nachdem man lange gesessen hat,
einfach ein bisschen stretchen
und dann geht es zum Mittagessen.
Ich habe leider sehr viele körperliche Probleme
im Verlauf meiner Karriere angehäuft.
Mein Physio sagt immer,
sitzen ist das neue Rauchen.
Deswegen gehe ich halt öfter mal zum Massieren
oder zum Physio, um einfach
anzugreifen oder Verletzungen zu behandeln.
Sitzen ist das neue Rauchen, da ist schon was dran.
So, wir gehen jetzt ins Kinderbällebad.
Bässe.
Wir versuchen halt,
die Leistung von den Talenten möglichst zu optimieren
und deswegen gehört das einfach dazu.
Natürlich gibt es ein paar Talente,
die jetzt nicht so ein Fan vom Sport sind.
Was ist da im Hintergrund gerade,
was passiert da auf der Erde gerade?
Deswegen gehört das einfach dazu.
Natürlich gibt es ein paar Talente,
die jetzt nicht so ein Fan vom Sport sind
und die muss man ein bisschen,
manchmal auch einen Arschtritt geben,
aber ja, dafür sind wir ja hier.
Herr Finn, komm her hier.
Der will nicht.
Ich wollte eigentlich auch im Fußball arbeiten,
da war ich eine längere Zeit...
Aber das ist wirklich nicht...
Man unterschätzt das unglaublich.
Es ist egal, ob E-Sport oder sonst was,
auch wenn man in der IT arbeitet,
den ganzen Tag vorm Rechner sitzt.
Bisschen Bewegung.
Wie gesagt, hätte ich das zu mir gesagt
vor 10 Jahren oder 15, ja 10 Jahre,
hätte ich auch gesagt, Max, ich weiß,
aber geh mir nicht auf den Sack.
Aber es ist echt ein Unterschied.
Man hat einfach viel, viel weniger Probleme.
Du hast keine Rückenschmerzen.
Du hast viel weniger Kopfweh.
Du hast keine Kreislaufsachen.
Du hast nichts mehr.
Egal was, du hast einfach nichts mehr.
Wenn du nicht wirklich krank bist und irgendwas hast,
ja, du hast einfach nichts mehr.
Jeden Tag sich eine Stunde bewegen,
das reicht schon im Endeffekt.
Natürlich ist es sicherlich nicht verkehrt,
auch zwischendurch mal die Treppe runter zu laufen,
was zu trinken zu holen,
die Treppe wieder zu hoch.
Aber du hast, ich will nicht sagen,
dass dann alles gut ist
und du musst auch super,
du musst auch keine super krasse
Ausdauersport-Sache oder sowas machen.
Es reicht, wenn du eine Stunde am Tag rausgehst
und einfach nur spazieren gehst.
Ja, es wäre natürlich besser,
wenn du dich ordentlich auch mal anstrengst,
ab und zu mal, ja, nicht verkehrt.
Und ich bin ja irgendwann sogar
selbst auch auf den Geschmack gekommen,
dass das nice ist,
ein bisschen rennen zu gehen,
ein bisschen Fahrrad zu fahren
und weiterhin einmal am Tag
so eineinhalb Stunden ein bisschen spazieren zu gehen,
zusätzlich.
Aber allein schon durch eine Stunde Bewegung
am Tag, ganz normal,
ohne große Anstrengung, Bewegung am Tag,
geht es einem so viel besser,
dass das wirklich gut investierte
60 Minuten sind.
Und selbst wenn es weniger ist,
jedes bisschen,
was nicht sitzen ist,
ist schon mal von Vorteil.
Ich bin in Krücken unterwegs gewesen
und in der Zeit bin ich auch
bei meinem anderen Hobby,
von Videogames, insbesondere von League of Legends,
sehr nachgegangen.
Wurde dann quasi gut in dem Spiel,
wurde von meinem ersten Team gescoutet
und bin halt dann so in die Szene als Spieler gekommen.
Nach meiner Spielerkarriere
wurde ich von meinem
damaligen
Manager, Lenz, angeschrieben
und der wollte mich halt hier für den Posten
als sportliche Leitung haben.
Warum warst du heute nicht neben mir?
Was war da los, Finn?
Ich habe eigentlich einen Ernährungsplan,
also,
bestimmte Anzahl an Kalorien,
ungefähr zwischen 2500
und 2700 am Tag.
Ich habe so
keinen Bock auf Kalorien zählen und sowas.
Ich habe meine Fitnessuhr,
die zeigt das so ungefähr an
und wenn ich ordentlich
gerade sonntags,
ich muss ja sagen, ich bin ja eigentlich blöd,
gerade wenn ich sonntags, heute nicht,
weil heute ist wirklich Schnee und Eis, da geht das nicht,
normalerweise mache ich sonntags
meine längere Laufrunde,
das sind dann meistens sowas zwischen
zehn und elf,
so zehn und ein halb bis elf Kilometer.
Das dauert
knapp über eine Stunde,
wenn man das
in gut schaffbarem Tempo rennt,
ohne dass man danach
komplett im Arsch ist für den restlichen Tag.
Und
dann sehe ich immer,
okay, meine Fitness-
Fitness-Tracker-Zeug
hat jetzt errechnet, das hat irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
850 Kalorien
gebraucht,
dieser Aufwand jetzt
und dann denke ich mir sonntags immer, okay,
jetzt hast du dich schon so angestrengt und so,
jetzt kannst du auch ordentlich fressen.
Also im Prinzip, das was weggeht,
wird wahrscheinlich dann mittags gleich wieder
draufgefressen.
Aber insgesamt muss ich sagen,
so blöd das jetzt klingt,
was ich gerade gesagt habe, insgesamt ist es trotzdem
viel, viel besser und bringt enorm viel.
Also allein schon, dass du dann vielleicht
ein bisschen, du hast dann dadurch trotzdem,
auch wenn du vielleicht jetzt nicht super abnimmst
die ganze Zeit oder nur sehr langsam abnimmst,
hast du dann trotzdem
mehr Ausdauer, vielleicht ein paar Muskeln
an Stellen, wo du vorher gar nicht wusstest,
dass man da Muskeln für braucht.
Also du bist insgesamt
deutlich fitter und das ist viel angenehmer,
selbst wenn du dann nicht einfach die ganze Zeit
Kilo um Kilo verlierst.
Also ich bin jetzt, ich habe an Weihnachten wieder
ein bisschen zugenommen, ich war ja bei knapp
und ich habe ja ein Foto gepostet
auf Twitter, knapp 90.
Jetzt bin ich wieder so, wenn ich mich da morgens
nackig mal auf die Waage stelle,
so 92.
Wenn ich ein paar Sachen anhabe, dann 93.
Also und vor allem,
nachdem ich jetzt durch das scheiß Wetter
auch nicht so viel rennen konnte,
also spätestens, wenn es wieder wärmer wird,
muss ich wieder meinen Zwei-Tages-Rhythmus da finden.
Aber trotzdem, mir geht es so
viel besser insgesamt. Ich meine,
ich bin immerhin runter von 108 auf
knapp 92 jetzt wieder.
Aber mir geht es so viel besser und
ich habe auch so viel mehr, ich bin 1,74.
Also immer noch
ziemlich pepo, na vielleicht jetzt nicht mehr
pepo fett, aber immer noch
pepo zu fett.
Was ist, was ist,
was kommt vor fett?
Es kommt normal,
es kommt zu dick.
Ich bin immer noch zu dick. Ich bin nicht zu fett,
ich bin zu dick, okay?
Ich bin immer noch zu dick.
Aber ich bin nicht mehr zu fett.
Aber es geht mir insgesamt so viel
besser,
dadurch, dass ich mich jetzt mehr bewege und das
macht auch Bock. Es ist echt so, dadurch, dass
ich jetzt quasi schon ein paar Tage nicht mehr gerannt
bin, jeder Tag
ist scheiße, weil ich mir so denke, ich würde jetzt ja
gerne, aber ich kann nicht, weil halt
alles vereist und verschneit ist. Ich muss mich
nachher mal aufs Fahrrad hocken hier.
Wenigstens ein bisschen, bisschen
was machen. Egal, gucken wir mal, fertig.
Ich wohne seit kurzem im Regensburg
mit meiner Freundin zusammen in einer
Vier-Zimmer-Wohnung, 78 Quadratmeter.
Hier ist das Wohnzimmer
und hier ist mein
Arbeitsbereich. Also den Großteil meines Tages
verbringe ich hier. Mein Arbeitstag beginnt
eigentlich immer gegen 9 Uhr morgens.
Das erste, was ich mache, ist immer
E-Mails checken, ob ein Kollege was
von mir braucht für die Förderung.
Und dann arbeite ich die ganzen Bürosachen
ab, was halt anliegt und
bin dann meistens so gegen 10 Uhr fertig
und dann streame ich und spiele Solo-Queue
zwei, drei Stunden. Ich kriege 3000
Euro brutto bei der
EPF, dann
520 Euro bei meinem Team
als Nebenjob. Ist eigentlich
sehr, sehr geil, weil das ist dann auch
netto. Aber das Gute ist,
also ich finde das super,
dass der nebenbei noch
selbst kompetitiv spielt, wenn er jetzt
bestimmt auch nicht auf super krass,
immer noch
besser als 99,9 Prozent
der Leute.
Coaches mit Praxiserfahrung
sind einfach mega nice. Muss man sagen,
keine Steuern zahlen.
Ich finde auch immer, wenn man sich
E-Sports Sachen anguckt und die Leute,
die das casten, ich persönlich
mag es, wenn die Caster selbst
gut in dem Game sind.
Ich habe das in Overwatch immer, ich muss
das sagen, weil das das einzige Spiel ist,
das ich in den letzten Jahren wirklich ernsthaft
mal versucht habe, kompetitiv zu spielen.
Du hattest da teilweise Caster,
die absolut keine Ahnung hatten, wovon sie
geredet haben. Es war so weird.
Und die
im Prinzip nichts gemacht haben, außer
die ganze Zeit wie verrückt zu hypen.
Man muss auch sagen, Overwatch ist ein Kack-Game
zu, zu observen
und zuzugucken.
Ich gucke mittlerweile, ich beschäftige mich null
mittlerweile mehr damit.
Aber
ich habe mir immer am liebsten Caster
angeguckt, wo ich wusste, okay, die spielen selbst
ganz gut und die wissen, was Sache ist. Die haben auch
oftmals dann
besser predikten können, wann, wie, wo
was passiert, anstatt einfach nur dieses
typische Hype
bei Overwatch gecaste, was du an vielen
Stellen hattest. So, oh, it's getting intense,
it's getting intense, wow!
Und du hast dir so gedacht, okay, niemand
versteht bei Overwatch, was eigentlich passiert.
Gerade da hattest du einen Caster gebraucht,
der das ordentlich
begleitet.
War aber nicht so.
Die waren Diamond, wenn es hochkommt, waren die Diamond.
Wenn es hochkommt.
Mittlerweile ist es wahrscheinlich
so, dass alle, die in diesen
Overwatch, gibt es die Overwatch League
eigentlich noch? Ich verfolge das null. Wie gesagt,
spätestens mit der Abwanderung
von Twitch auf YouTube
habe ich instant, habe ich sofort gestoppt,
mir alles anzugucken. Und
was in Overwatch ganz weird war,
ist, dass sogar Spieler gesagt haben,
in ihren Streams,
eigentlich würden sie jetzt viel lieber was anderes
machen und haben überhaupt keinen Bock auf das Game,
aber sie
verdienen halt ihr Geld damit, so.
Das habe ich legit
von einem CS-Pro oder von einem LoL-Pro
oder sowas nie gehört, in der
Richtung.
Haben sie das nicht
eingestellt? Kann sein.
Keine Ahnung. Gibt es die Overwatch
League noch?
Ich habe wirklich absolut keinen Plan.
Das ist ja auch so eine super schwammige,
das ist ja auch so eine
super schwammige Aussage, ja.
So nach dem Motto, ey, gibt es
eine Overwatch League 2024? Und dann
sagen sie, Overwatch remains
committed to competitive ecosystem in
2024 and beyond.
Das ist so, das ist so, management
speak 1x1.
Antworte, ohne zu
antworten.
Ja, im Endeffekt hat er gesagt,
Overwatch wird auch weiterhin,
wie kann man das überhaupt
gescheit übersetzen, Mann?
Overwatch wird auch weiterhin
so viel Wert darauf
legen, ein
competitive Ökosystem
für Spieler in 2024 und
darauf zu liefern.
So sinngemäß. Das ist so
null, das ist so gar nichts.
Das ist einfach nur die Aussage, Mann.
So ungefähr, sagen wir mal,
150 bis 200 Euro Streaming
Einnahmen im Monat. Also
netto komme ich insgesamt
ungefähr auf 2.900
bis 3.000, je nachdem.
Doch okay.
Ja, wie das
Monat läuft. Also ich denke schon, dass
sich mein Job lohnt. Es ist jetzt kein
lebensnotwendiger Job, wie
zum Beispiel eine Krankenschwester.
Aber wir sind eigentlich
Entertainer, muss man sagen. Und, äh,
es ist ja auch viel wert, wenn Leute
einfach, also die systemrelevant
sind, abends nach Hause kommen
und einfach nur abschalten wollen und
irgendwas gucken können. Und das sind wir.
Also da helfen wir halt.
Hat er nicht unrecht.
Überschuss. Sicherlich auch ETF-Enjoyer.
Der spielt ein Boardgame,
weil die gesagt haben, setz dich mal
an den PC, klick ein bisschen rum
und rede in die Kamera. Ja.
Deswegen spielt er
ein Boardgame.
Das war mein Tag als E-Sports Coach.
Ich hoffe, es hat euch gefallen.
Andere Videos gibt's hier und hier.
Über Kommentare und Likes freuen wir uns
natürlich immer.
Excellent freuen wir uns da drüber.
Ich mich auch, Leute.
Oh, was ist denn hier die massive
discussion hier? Früher war...
Was? Äh, okay. Keine Ahnung, was es
geht.
In Österreich geht das anscheinend noch.
In Berlin eher nicht.
Wobei in Berlin geht auch
so vieles nicht.
In Berlin gehen beispielsweise so Basics, wie
Wahlzettel auszählen, auch nicht
richtig. Aber in Berlin ist das
eh durch, ja. Kannst du mal
ein Video reinschicken? Ja.
Gaming Latency on Linux.
Gibt's einen Unterschied?
Zwischen
KDE und Gnome?
Da ist bestimmt
i3 auch gut, was Input Delay
angeht. Ist ein bisschen
cringe. Oh ne, dann kann ich mir das jetzt nicht angucken.
Was ist das? Computerspiele
Sucht?
Und die Verkaufstricks, die
ist der Hersteller.
Oh ne, 21.
Oh, das ist bestimmt
cringe. Das kann ich mir jetzt nicht geben. Ich mach's
mal auf für irgendwie eines der nächsten.
Das kann ich...
ZDF-Video über Gaming. Ne, das kann...
Das halte ich jetzt... Das geht jetzt grad nicht.
Wir hatten hier auch noch ein anderes Video
offen, wo Leute gemeint haben, das ist gar nicht schlecht.
Und zwar...
Äh, hier.
Boreout kaputt
durch Unterforderung. Wobei das gute
Bewertungen hat. Was ist
sonst noch hier? Was ist das denn?
Der peinliche
Absturz von NFTs.
Da muss ich kein Video
zugucken. Es reicht
schon, wenn man so
Mainstream
gepostet sich angucken, feststellt,
dass NFTs die letzten zwei Jahre
eigentlich... Oh, sagen wir das letzte Jahr eigentlich kaum noch eine
Rolle gespielt haben. Großartig.
Natürlich hast du immer irgendwelche Leute,
die dir permanent erzählen wollen.
Das wird jetzt doch hier richtig und krass und geil
und super und NFTs. Und dann
sind dann irgendwelche Spieleunternehmen
darauf aufmerksam geworden und wollten dann auch irgendwelche
NFT-Sachen rausbringen. Aber jucken
tut's eigentlich kein mehr seit einem Jahr.
Das ist 28 Minuten. Das ist mir
eigentlich zu lang. Wisst ihr, was
das Schlimmste ist? Wenn ich grad
dieses... Ich glaub, das hab ich letzten sogar schon gesagt.
Wisst ihr, was das Schlimmste ist? Normalerweise
würde ich ja sagen, ey, weißt du was? Dann
sitzt du halt da und guckst den ganzen Tag
aufs Handy an. Wenn du dafür Geld kriegst, okay.
Das Schlimmste ist,
wenn du Beschäftigung
faken musst, wo keine
Beschäftigung ist.
In der Situation war wahrscheinlich jeder schon mal.
Es ist eigentlich grad nichts
Großartiges zu tun,
aber gerade wenn du im Büro sitzt,
wenn dann irgendwie einer durchläuft,
musst du immer so tun, als würdest du
gerade was machen. Das ist abfuck.
So dieses...
Eigentlich ist es scheiße, aber ich muss so tun,
als hätte ich was. Da kommt dann irgendjemand rein
und macht so...
Alles klar, alles klar, und der Typ ist raus.
Okay, jetzt erst mal wieder Twitch auf.
Ist glücklicherweise
schon lange nicht mal so gewesen,
aber die Situation kennt wahrscheinlich jeder.
Das ist...
Das ist nervig. Also das ist wirklich dumm.
Hast du eigentlich schon mal was zum Thema
NixOS angeschaut? Nee,
aber ich habe NixOS,
glaub ich, seit gefühlt zwei
Jahren in
meiner Müssten-wir-uns-mal-angucken-Liste
stehen. Dann los,
ne, jetzt nicht.
Bei euch ist Twitch geblockt? Ich weiß gar nicht, ob Twitch...
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob Twitch
bei mir auf der Arbeit geblockt ist oder nicht.
Ich würde mir aber,
wenn überhaupt, auch Twitch gar nicht auf dem
großen Monitor auf dem Arbeits-Notebook
angucken, sondern entweder wenn ich
gerade am Essen bin oder
am Platz hocke oder irgendwie gerade mal
echt nix los ist, dann würde ich
das nebenbei auf dem Handy anmachen, irgendwie reinhören
oder so.
Aber nicht dort auf dem Notebook anmachen.
Hast du schon Erfahrung? Klar, jeder
in meinem Alter hat mal ein bisschen Kontakt
mit WoW gehabt, aber ich habe World of
Warcraft tatsächlich sehr wenig
gespielt im Vergleich zu manch anderem.
In meinem Alter.
Und ich habe auch nicht vor, WoW zu spielen.
Ich habe damals hauptsächlich
Dark gecrindet
und das ist echt so das MMO, was ich seit
20 Jahren spiele, ohne dass es langweilig wird.
Ja, aktuell auch immer noch.
Oder wieder, wieder noch, ja.
Also nicht auf live,
live kannst du vergessen.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch hier?
Steam Deck Alternative.
Ist mir eigentlich egal.
Was ist das denn?
IT-Sicherheit.
Okay, das geht nur drei Minuten.
Was ist das?
Warum Münchner Schulen Einfallstore für Hacker sind
von vor zwei Wochen. Keine Ahnung, warum ich das offen habe.
Es gibt bloß drei Minuten. Lass mal kurz, lass mal kurz.
Okay, ich rate mal,
warum Münchner Schulen
Einfallstore für Hacker sind.
Weil die kein Geld haben und
irgendwelche semi
sich gut auskennenden Lehrer
sich um die IT-Infrastruktur kümmern.
Doch, ich schon.
Ich finde Abo-Modelle
von Spielen richtig gut.
Weil guckt euch an, wo uns der ganze
Free-to-Play-Shit die letzten Jahre über hingebracht hat.
Abo-Modell finde...
Abo-Modell ist in der heutigen
Zeit ein bisschen außer Mode gekommen.
Aber ich finde Abo-Modell richtig gut.
Wohlgemerkt,
unter der Voraussetzung,
dass alle,
die den
Spiele-Abonnement
abgeschlossen haben,
dann auch die gleichen Voraussetzungen haben.
Was ich nicht gut finde, ist
ein Bronze, ein Silber, ein Gold-Abo
oder dann noch zusätzlich
irgendwelche Transactions und Jobs
mit Fortnite. Das finde ich für'n Arsch.
Was ich gut finde, ist das klassische
Online-Gaming-Abo-Model.
Du bezahlst 10 Euro im Monat,
dass du spielen kannst, aber der Rest
ist für alle, die das Abo-Modell bezahlen,
gleich. Das finde ich gut.
Das hat auch für den Hersteller
einen großen Vorteil, weil
die wissen, dass
nicht 90% der Abos
von einem auf den anderen Monat wegfallen.
Das ist auch so eine gewisse Planungssicherheit
für den Hersteller. Und ein Abo
ist auch
für uns gut
als Spieler,
weil der Hersteller seine Spiele
eben auf
Gameplay
einfach nur gutes Gameplay optimieren
kann, ohne Sachen künstlich
in die Länge zu ziehen, ohne
Sachen wegzulassen und sonst was,
sondern einfach ganz
entspannt von finanziellen
Finanzierungsstrategien
ein Spiel
entwickeln kann, was am besten für
die Spieler, soweit in der Theorie,
für die Spieler ist.
Ich finde Abo-Modelle eigentlich,
wenn es um
Spielefinanzierung geht, für beide Seiten
mit das Beste. Es ist etwas
aus der Mode gekommen und
viele Leute sind es heute auch nicht mehr gewöhnt
und fassen halt auch Spiele mit Abo-Modellen gar nicht an.
Ich finde Abo-Modelle für beide
Seiten eigentlich das Beste, was es gibt.
Wie viel RAM-Verbrauch ich hab?
Weiß ich nicht. Nicht so viel.
32? Nee.
Doch.
GB. Und da läuft aber auch noch eine 4M mit
zumindest
zugewiesen 64 GB RAM.
Von denen sind 20 FreeSense.
Ja, also
ich hab zu viel RAM.
Und das Schlimme ist,
wisst ihr, was echt Painschamp wird?
Wisst ihr, was echt Painschamp wird?
Mein nächster Rechner braucht
128 GB RAM.
Weil ich verdopple RAM immer.
Und es macht keinen Sinn.
Es macht keinen Sinn.
Ich will nicht, ich weiß nicht, ob ich
immer bisher meinen RAM verdoppelt habe.
Aber lasst uns doch mal
überlegen. Lasst uns doch mal überlegen.
Mein allerallererster Rechner,
das war irgendein
so ein, das war irgendein
AMD K6. Noch was?
Ich glaube,
der hatte 8 oder 16 MB RAM.
Der nächste hatte, glaube ich,
schon 16 oder 32.
Sagen wir mal 32 MB RAM.
Das war dann Pentium 2.
Oh, ich krieg das gar nicht mehr richtig zusammen.
Danach hatte ich nach dem Pentium 2
hatte ich, glaube ich,
einen Athlon XP.
Das kommt doch ungefähr hin, oder?
Wie kamen die Dinger dann raus?
Ja, ja, ja, das kommt ungefähr hin.
Dann hatte ich einen Athlon XP.
Der hatte, glaube ich, schon einen Gigabyte
Speicher.
Dann,
dann hatte ich einen Core,
Core Duo, Core to Duo, glaube ich,
irgendwann.
Oder einen,
nee, nee, nee, nee,
dazwischen hatte ich noch so einen,
wie hießen die ersten Dual-Core-Dinger
von AMD?
Und sind die Server-Dinger
Toledo?
Gab's das noch?
Ja.
Athlon 64 X2.
Release Date?
Toledo, genau.
2005.
So, dann hatte ich schon irgendwie Core, Core Dings
Duo oder so,
was es noch gab.
Der hatte dann wahrscheinlich
8 Gig.
Und das nächste
war 16, das nächste war 32.
Und jetzt den hier,
64.
Wenn man davon ausgeht, dass die Rechner immer
2 bis 5 Jahre hielten,
da kommt das doch ungefähr hin, oder?
Dass ich bisher immer mindestens den Ramp
von Rechnerkauf zu Rechnerkauf
verdoppelt hab.
Aber jetzt macht's keinen Sinn.
Warum?
Alle 2 bis 5 Jahre ist doch ein vollkommen normaler
Intervall, sich neue
Rechner zu kaufen. Früher eher alle
2 Jahre, jetzt eher alle 5 Jahre.
Im Durchschnitt vielleicht so
alle 3. Das ist doch vollkommen normaler
Intervall. Da musst du gar kein Geld scheißen
dafür. War ein bisschen viel, oder?
Dann war das damals ein bisschen viel.
Ich glaub, dann hatte ich gar
kein Core-to-Duo, sondern gleich nen
ähm, nen i3
oder sowas als nächstes dann.
Also, meinen letzten Rechner hatte ich 5 Jahre.
Mein letzter Rechner war
ein...
Was war denn mein letzter?
Was war denn mein letzter Rechner?
Ich glaub, nen i5? Moment, Moment.
Wir haben doch hier.
Easy, haben doch alles.
Hier, 8700K.
8700K
war mein letzter Rechner.
mit, äh,
das hab ich dann irgendwie ein halbes Jahr später oder so eingebaut,
mit einer
1080Ti.
Und die Kombination hielte 5 Jahre.
Die CPU
war für die damalige Zeit mega schnell und
eine 1080Ti war auch ihrer Zeit echt voraus.
Die hielt richtig, richtig gut mit.
Richtig lange Zeit.
Und jetzt hab ich mir vor ungefähr genau nem Jahr
einen neuen
gekauft mit
13.900K und
4090.
Das wird auch ne Weile halten.
So sieht's aus.
Okay. Jetzt kommen wir mal zu eigentlich,
warum Münchner Schulen einfach so...
Wir lassen das einfach mal durchlaufen. Drei Minuten.
Wie gesagt, meine Vermutung ist, weil
irgendwelche...
sagen wir mal so, semi-kompetenten
Lehrer in IT-Security sich um
die IT-Infrastruktur
der Schule in ihrer Freizeit kümmern.
Hackers.
Ich find die Sprecher teilweise
so cringe bei diesen Schreiträgern.
Auch in Bayern? Die wagen
es! Auch in Bayern!
Grüß Gott!
Wie kann man einfach in Bayern das
machen?
Das Hauptproblem ist einfach, dass die
Kinderdaten nahezu offen im Internet
sind, wenn es den Hackern so einfach gemacht wird,
hier die Systeme zu hacken.
Ein Beispiel.
Der Webmailer... Warum?
Ist immer eine blöde Frage. Vielleicht liegt's noch
am Wetter. Warum sehen alle Schulen
in Deutschland immer so runtergekommen
kacke aus? Und die sieht
ja noch ganz, ganz brauchbar aus im Vergleich.
Guckt euch die Werner-von-Siemann-Schule an
in Frankfurt, äh... Guckt euch
die Werner-von-Siemann-Schule in Frankfurt
an, Mann. Noch besser
finde ich die Bilder, wenn du dir
die Werner-von-Siemann-Schule anguckst in...
Wo...
Wo sind die Bilder hin?
Wo ist die Matratze?
Also ich gebe zu, die Schule
sieht gegen die Werner-von-Siemann-Schule
noch gut aus, ja?
Aber warum
sehen alle Schulen immer so runtergekommen aus?
Ein Beispiel.
Der Webmailer
vieler Grund- und Hauptschulen
wie hier in München... Moment, ich hab
nicht zugehört. Der was? Der was?
Der Webmailer... Der Webmailer!
Alles klar.
... vieler Grund- und Hauptschulen
wie hier in München
ist völlig veraltet.
IT-Sicherheitsexperte
Florian Hansemann zeigt uns,
was das bedeutet.
Alter!
Das ist ja 2004,
Mann!
Dass es das noch gibt!
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es das
noch gibt!
Das war 2005
oder so war angesagt.
Das ist ernsthaft,
das gibt's noch!
...
Dass das überhaupt noch jemand
benutzt, wusste ich überhaupt nicht.
Ey, das ist doch
top aktuell!
5.2, 2.3
Letztes Stable-Release, nur vor
drei Jahren, Mann!
Das Problem ist, dass das halt irgendein
Patch-Update ist, wo sich nie was dran getan hat, ey.
Wahnsinn,
dass es das noch gibt, ey.
Die Domain der Münchner Schulen
musin.de nutzt einen
Webmailer mit dem Namen Horde.
Und der hat seit Juni
2020 keine Updates
mehr erhalten. Also, ohne Scheiß, ich hatte gedacht, dass er
das ist älter. Das war 2005
angesagt.
Ein Riesenproblem.
Denn Schwachstellen werden nicht
Guck mal, es basiert noch auf PHP 5.3.
Ist PHP 5? Oder war's
PHP 4? Was ist jetzt außer Support?
Ah, ja, hier.
August 2014.
Nice.
... mehr erhalten.
Ein Riesenproblem.
Denn Schwachstellen werden nicht
mehr geschlossen. Hacker können sie
ausnutzen. Oh, gute Maus.
Die hab ich auf der Arbeit auch. Logitech
G502. Also, wenn Hacker
jetzt diese Daten erbeuten, könnten sie das
beispielsweise als Identitätsdiebstahl verwenden.
Sich irgendwie als Kind ausgeben, die
Personalien von denen übernehmen, die Anschrift von denen
raussuchen, Stalking. Diese ganzen Themen
sind dann auch betroffen.
Verantwortlich für die IT-Sicherheit an
Bayerns Schulen ist der sogenannte
Sachaufwandsträger.
Alter,
wir sind so übertrieben
bürokratisch, Mann. Und wir haben für jeden
Scheiß irgendein eigenes Wort.
In diesem ... Sicherheit an Bayerns
Schulen ist der sogenannte
Sachaufwandsträger. Der Sachaufwandsträger,
Alter. In diesem Fall ist
das die Stadt München. Sie teilt
auf Anfrage des BR mit,
die
Ablösung vom Horde-Web-Client
erfolgt in einem laufenden, weitreichenden
Umstrukturierungsprojekt.
Ziel ist es, die Ablösung
für die Bildungsarmen und ohne Einschränkungen
für die Bildungsarmen ...
Okay, Bullshit-Laber 1x1
auch hier erfüllt.
... Einrichtungen vorzunehmen.
Die haben im Prinzip einfach nur gesagt,
sie planen, dass es demnächst
mal irgendwann vielleicht
ersetzt wird.
Das ist keine Antwort auf die Frage,
warum setzt ihr so ein Outdate und Shit ein?
Also die Usability ist scheiße,
kommt ja noch dabei.
Und es passiert einer PHP 5.3, Mann.
Im Klartext,
das wird wohl noch dauern.
Übrigens,
das Kultusministerium
erlaubt Lehrern in einem
Zitat vertretbaren Maß
technische IT-Administration
von Hard- und Software
selbst vorzunehmen.
Ja, das müssen die ja wahrscheinlich auch,
weil sonst keiner was macht.
Heißt, IT-Sicherheit ist ein Stück weit
auch Sache der Lehrer.
Ja, die machen das bestimmt nicht, weil sie sich denken,
ich kann mir nachmittags nicht Geileres
mehr vorstellen. Die machen das, weil sonst
gar nichts passiert. Also den Lehrern würde ich
gar nicht den Vorwurf machen an der Stelle.
Der Bayerische Lehrerverband sieht da große Mängel.
Schulen
haben IT-Systeme,
die durchaus vergleichbar sind
mit einer mittelständischen Firma.
In einer mittelständischen Firma
ist ein
festangestellter ITler vorhanden.
Es ist jemand, eine Fachkraft.
Genau, habt ihr das gehört? Genau ein ITler
ist vorhanden.
Die in diesem Bereich ausgebildet ist.
Das sind dann die ITler,
die in Stellenanzeigen immer gesucht werden,
die Windows,
Linux, VMware,
Telefonanlage,
Mobile-Apps,
Web-Store
und alles in einem machen
und nebenbei noch bei Projekten
mithelfen,
vor Ort sind, durch ganz Deutschland fahren
und das Handy vom Chef
immer wieder neu flashen.
Für
30k im Jahr.
Und dann sich beschweren
bei der Bitkom und sagen
Fachkräftemangel, wir finden niemand.
Und genau so sollte es
eigentlich an den Schulen sein.
Wir brauchen hier eine bessere
Ausstattung.
Der Elternverband sagt,
die Verwendung alter Webmailer sei höchst
bedenklich, auch im Hinblick auf die
Datenschutzgrundverordnung, kurz
DSGVO.
Ey, ob die den
outdateden Webmailer verwenden.
Das ist nicht der Webmailer.
Also,
es ist nicht das Problem, dass es jetzt
ein E-Mail-Programm
im Browser ist.
Im Hinblick auf die Datenschutzgrundverordnung, kurz.
Das ist das Problem, dass es outdated as fuck ist
und vor allem auf PHP 5.3 noch basiert.
Und wahrscheinlich
von außen erreichbar ist.
DSGVO.
Es macht natürlich nervös.
Nicht ohne Grund,
ähm, das sieht die
DSGVO ja auch vor. Die Daten von
Minderjährigen, die müssen ganz besonders geschützt werden,
weil die Kinder, die können sich nicht wehren.
Und das sind die leidtragenden Ansprüche.
Die Kinder könnten das wahrscheinlich besser.
Los.
Für den Münchner Rechtsanwalt mag
zumindest die etwas technisch versierten
Maisch ist der Einsatz
des veralteten Webmailers sogar
ein klarer Verstoß gegen die Datenschutzgrundverordnung.
Nun verlangt aber
die Datenschutzgrundverordnung, dass man
Maßnahmen trifft, die nach dem aktuellen
Stand der Technik funktionieren.
Und, ähm, in dem Fall würde ich sagen...
Das ist halt auch super schwammig, ne?
Das kann ja alles heißen.
...gibt es überhaupt keine andere Lösung,
als hier auf diesen Webmailer zu verzichten
und ein neues Webmail-System einzuführen.
Nach den BR-Recherchen schickt Anwalt
Marc Maisch dem Bayerischen Datenschutzbeauftragten
nun eine Beschwerde.
Oh!
Ja, dann wird er...
Na dann, dann wird er sich natürlich denken,
okay, jetzt aber...
Das...
Wisst ihr, wisst ihr, was der
Datenschutzbeauftragte, wie der dann guckt?
Der guckt wie dieses
Oh-No-Anyway-Meme.
Oh, no!
Anyway!
So guckt er dann.
Oh, no! Anyway!
Das geht dem sonst wo vorbei, ey.
Hm.
Ja, die wollen da kein Geld für ausgeben.
Oh, no.
Kennt ihr das?
Nein.
Also, YouTube ist echter Meinung.
Ich möchte unbedingt Videos von mir gucken.
Ja, easy. Nein, nein, das nicht, nicht.
Ich soll meine, meine Videos, so will ich, soll ich gucken.
Guck ich meine Videos, kein Problem.
Chat. Easy.
Schade, dass Venice so reingeschissen hat.
Das hat richtig Bock gemacht,
so ohne Blaufilter
und mit ein paar Spielern
und höheren Tickrate-Servern und so.
War eigentlich richtig, richtig nice.
Burnout und Hustle-Culture.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch, ey?
Ich krieg...
Ich hab richtig Hunger gerade.
Wisst ihr das?
PepoFatTime.
Kurz raus.
Die Nudel mit Lachs rufen.
Chat, woher wisst ihr das?
Woher wisst ihr das,
dass es bei mir Nudeln mit Lachs gibt?
Ich dachte, ich dachte, das ist
secret.
Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich hast du sogar recht.
Ja, ja, hast du recht.
Leute, ich geh jetzt was essen.
Bis gleich, 12.
Gestern...
Das war PvP richtig nice.
Hätte ich eigentlich streamen sollen.
Oh, wenn das viele nicht interessiert.
Aber ein paar gucken ja doch immer ganz gern zu.
War richtig nice.
Wir haben alles zerstört, ey.
Alles gebasht.
So wie das sein muss.
So erstellst du deine eigene Cloud.
Leute, ich weiß nicht, wie oft ich sagen soll.
NextCloud hat zwar Cloud im Namen,
hat aber mit Cloud überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Es ist ein stinknormal
lokal installierte PHP-Software.
Hat einfach nur Cloud im Namen.
Und es ist auch eine nervige Software,
die ich sehr ungerne verwende.
Cover als Paketsklave,
die Titel teilweise.
Gut, ich geh jetzt meinen Lachs futtern
mit Nudeln. Wir hören uns nachher
vielleicht. Bis dann, macht's gut.
See you.